you
you
you
you
hey welcome to the team coco 24 hour
mobile
gaming marathon that's right it's gonna
be pretty cool and uh i have a guitar
here
to create the illusion that i might be
playing some music
sometime in the next 24 hours maybe well
maybe it won't
probably won't not a big draw if i did
anyway who cares
but you don't know what's going to
happen this will be really great
so stick with us quit your job
leave your loved one to drink a lot of
caffeine
red bull mix red bull with other forms
of red bull
and uh just go for it just go for it and
stay up for 24 hours
this is the most important thing you'll
ever do unless you
you know join the armed services or um
help the needy or teach
i think teaching's important this might
not be that important
anyway have fun i'll be checking in
every now and then
see you later
hey everybody well it's one echo 24-hour
mobile marathon sponsored by google play
yeah
yes oh everyone's clapping on screen
this is great thank you for joining us
uh for the next 24 hours uh we're going
to be playing
all the greatest games on the google
play store live
interacting with you on facebook twitch
and
youtube we're gonna have a bunch of
special guests a bunch of exclusive
musical performances we got costumes we
got snacks we got a lot of coffee it's
gonna be a great time
uh and to kick everything off i think we
should introduce
the one the only mr conan o'brien let's
get him in here
yes look at this look at this oh yeah
yeah
great i'm great good i'm good thank you
for coming
let's explain something right i can't
have gum
oh here i'll just you know hold that
listen let me explain something
just hold that for 24 hours oh god hold
that
okay you know what you can get for that
on ebay because you're still on ebay
yes there's still an ebay yes see i'm
still with it i don't
throw shade at tyga um say hi to people
on twitch youtube and facebook
okay uh hey twitch facebook what else
uh youtube youtube
youtube face twitch book uh those of you
out there
welcome to our world now listen let's
copy something right away
that first part with the guitar come on
it was a pre-tape
right because then i'm wearing a
different sweater
but that was the only pre-tape that was
the only one that's right that's right
that was the only one we just did that
as a test
but now this is me i am wearing uh this
brown sweater and i'm here do we
talk to individual people this is
important you got to stay up for all 24
hours
if you have a job quit that job that job
isn't important
this is important oh i dropped your gum
you idiot sorry i'm just gonna put it
over here just throw it over there all
right just throw it there everything
here is fake uh
yeah so yeah we're gonna play a bunch of
great games you love you gotta take it
down a little bit okay
this is this is a marathon all right
this is a marathon
uh and you are your energy's way up here
bring it down here okay because you've
got to last for you're going to be up
for all of 24 hours i'm going to be up
for 24 hours
you might be up for 34 hours that's why
would we be up for 34. i do an extra 10.
oh my gosh i binge watch breaking bad
after this is over
it's my plan first two seasons anyway
what's up all right so i thought we'd
play a game to start things off it's
called monument valley 2.
yes monument valley yeah is excellent
it's a put do you like puzzles who
doesn't like puzzles yeah all right did
you like uh
that guy mcesher remember who doesn't
yes escher he was a hand drawing a hand
yeah the hang out
the hand everyone who's ever gone to a
college dorm room has seen
roxy escher right so we're gonna play uh
we're gonna play this uh game monument
valley too
uh so let's go to it now and uh do you
want to play yeah okay what are you
talking about here we go what do you do
and look see it's right on the side of
us right here see it see see it's right
there yeah okay
okay i just just settle down i'm excited
you act i'm blown away by all this
technology
you lose your credibility as someone
who's in the tech world that's okay you
are still
like oh my god there's a screen but it's
happening there's a camera and there's a
screen
yeah all right so what do we do i just
realized i touched my face that had your
gum on it i got my hand that's right all
right so
you you press the uh thing there you
wanna get now you have herpes
uh yeah yeah can't get it twice all
right so um i
you want to get uh ro uh the little girl
there up to
the the top that top uh platform yes so
you
you press basically wherever you press
she'll walk
right there she is she's walking yeah
yeah and
of course there's nowhere to go here so
you have to how do i figure out oh how
can is there a way to
make that lower can i lower that it says
hold and rotate
yeah so why not just lower that look at
that see it's like all about
see look at the emcee escheri yeah but i
don't want that part to move
no yeah you want to make the bridge you
want to get the bridge there oh there it
is
you got it yeah and then bang nailed it
insane
yeah bang and there she goes
exactly can i have her jump off uh no
you don't want to
we are her we don't want to make her
jump off she looks depressed no she's
not she's excited
all right she's excited look at this
this beautiful new world we have here
okay is this amazing yeah this is
amazing i turn up the volume so we can
hear this
this is why the gross national product
the united states is plummeting
because everyone's huddled in their
little cubes playing these games where
things go nowhere
staying up for 24 hours this is an
experience it's an experience it's not
just a game it's it's uh it could change
your life you've got to take it down all
right i want to beat you today i've had
four coffees i know just settle down
you're acting like an ins uh uh crazy
wolverine
what's next well all right so hit the uh
the little uh
the flashing thing yes yeah yeah there
we go okay
uh this is a great game who makes it hey
crooked johnny what's up
uh i'm not sure but you can find it on
the google play store
there we go oh please say hi patrick in
german
hello patrick that was you said hello
patrick
that was english you just said it louder
oh that wasn't
sorry patrick yeah there we go all right
uh thurnin uh uthman says conan
you need to go ultra instinct okay what
do i do
i don't know uh try hitting the flashing
thing yeah here we go
ultra instinct thanks uthannan we're
doing it it's loading
that's right terracotta kid it's not
pre-recorded because we're saying your
name yeah exactly and guess what
if you stay up for 24 hours you're gonna
watch us watch things load
that'll be about six hours of the 24s
watching things
loads ro introduces your child to the
valley the vestibule oh the vegetable in
which row introduces her child to the
valley
okay i'm ready to go yeah you're ready
to introduce some children
okay okay all right so
again this is yeah so maybe we just want
to get to the is that a
that looks like cheeto dust square
it's a i'm trying to move her forward
but that's where cheetos come from trees
oh this is our child we're introducing
her to the valley
oh okay so she's taking her so she has a
child yes
you know depressed woman with a child
if she wants to be a good mom she needs
to take care of herself first and that
takes care of the mom
look they say put your mask on before
helping others in like a plane
you know do you ever yes that's a good
analogy that's been way overused by
everybody all right
all right now what happens uh i don't
know oh essie
i've never played whales with him
[Applause]
three dimensions four dimensions nine
dimensions
are we really here are we really
anywhere all right what do i do how do i
make
i want to go here try it yeah try
turning the thing the the
the little spigot oh there you go oh wow
look at this see nearly whipping it
ultra instinct just like someone on the
internet told him to do
thomas someone conan will never meet
someone conan will never know
told conan to do something and now he is
uh i think you want to get to that that
that square yes yeah i'm getting there
hold on all right we're going this way
now
all right right where do you apply for a
conan internship a2
i go to using this as a job opportunity
we're here trying to create harmony in a
world that's fracturing rapidly
we're trying to bring the world together
you're like one question
my internship i'm applying to brown
that was just little secretions coming
out your eyes um
i'm trying to get to this thing no you
don't use this to get a job
this is the greatest thing that ever
happened to anybody i'm not really
playing the game i'm mostly just yelling
at that person who asked for an
internship
now will they get an internship probably
the bar is pretty low here at conan i
used to be an intern
yeah you were an intern you still are
technically an intern that's true we're
not paying you yet
that's really true no we once hired
someone as an intern and three weeks
later we found out that they were a mop
they were a mop and uh look at that i
did it and i'm not even really paying
attention to be honest with you randy
bob says they don't want the internship
anymore
ah i don't want the internship
that's too big insurance
you don't want this internship anyway we
don't even feed our interns
yeah we have old pea soup that we found
in the commissary that we give them
just chew on smartest thing you ever did
you want to work on a show like ellen i
think
everybody who interns there yes they get
like a porsche yeah
oh yeah they give them a porsche their
first day interning they
they're dressed well here we give you a
prison tattoo
a tattoo i don't even know what i'm
doing now what am i doing i uh
i'm just rotating things no you're doing
well you're doing well you just yeah
rotate the thing like you were and then
go across there to the old uh
to the other golden square you want to
get to the yeah that older uh
depressed woman with her daughter that
she clearly doesn't love
she can't she's so depressed herself
exactly all right
adam says conan my hair i want to see
some of the sweet dance moves there's no
music to dance to you don't just
listen to this ethereal listen there's
ethereal music on the game
oh this is i feel uncomfortable it's
very
uh this is very craft work
this is very very slow and this is
this is the kind of music what are you
doing i was just protecting my i was i
thought that was a setup for you
punching me i thought it was like an
elaborate setup that you were just going
to come
way too much you're you're not in a good
place no spiritually oh this turns that
too
there we go all right you're good at
this gear natural monument valley too
well you know what thank you that's the
stupidest thing anyone's ever said to me
how do i get them up there i gotta get
to those stairs that's the problem
splatulated no this is not 24 hours of
monument valley too we're going to be
playing a lot of games
yes people are just wondering if this is
going to be 25 oh no
oh if you were worried about this being
at all disappointing
oh no perish the thought
we're not going to be playing monument
valley the whole time we're going to be
playing
all kinds of different games and i'm
going to pop back in every hour so
you never know what's going to happen
here right exactly this could be the
most exciting 24 hours of your life
unless you've ever done anything else
do you do you want to play a different
game yeah uh
i think the original name of this game
was watching paint drive
but yeah so uh there's another great
game called uh lumio city oh
ahmed ali ali says punch him
don't got i'm trying to load the game
yes now
i'm loading why are you so abusive conan
you know what
i was the middle of six children now
some might say
how can you be the middle of six
mathematically that's a problem
well um not an easy childhood
and i'm working on a lot of stuff but
blair i really do love you people think
don't see
the way he cringes when i pat him on the
back that means i've never heard him in
his life
uh so we're gonna play uh so this game
is lumio city what's cool about this
game is oh someone wanted me to bring
jordan
no no i just did a trip
it's coming out in a couple it'll be out
soon right i did a trip yeah i took
jordan to italy yes and it's it's
really weird and really funny i think
it's i'm very happy with it i think uh
comedically
it's one of uh the most insane things
we've ever done
i lost my mind uh he broke my he broke
my brain yeah jordan so watch for that
he broke all of us uh but it would say
hi to my
karen and oh it went by too quickly hi i
think friend karen someone wanted me to
say hi to karen
this this is lumio city let me ask
what's great about this game is uh
it's another gorgeous game but it also
they made
real uh sets for this and they animated
over it so
uh would you rather me play the game or
watch you play the game
okay okay because that might be more
entertaining sure yes oh look that's
fine
okay here we are that's fine well yes
and look look we're right over the uh
see where little couches over the game
there oh that's so look at that
it's incredible there we go all right uh
so i think this is
this is our dad this is our father i
think
there's our granddad there we go uh
conan take your family to japan on
vacation i did
i took my family to japan on vacation
last april
uh so about 11 months ago we had an
amazing time
wonderful i bet a lot of people
recognized you there
because the people go crazy for you they
were in other countries
it was nice uh it was a great we had a
great experience
japan is was fantastic everywhere i go
now
everywhere i go uh korean people come up
to me
i've got so many nice oh in italy it was
it was insane yes and when we were in
italy there are koreans in italy
it's it's amazing somebody was saying
they thought because
they airbnb their houses for the
olympics uh
yuri chemnick says conan i adore your
abusive nature
yes thank you wrong answer
all right i can't play for 24 hours with
a with a bum
uh with a bum arm yeah all right uh
granddad's gone our granddad's been
taken oh
this is the story what's the narrative
granddad's gone this is a fun game for
kids
i don't think this is just for kids i
think it's for everybody someone stole
an old man
music by ed critchley man i love
critchley
sounds by alistair lindsey we could tap
we can look in the
bag here okay someone stole an old man
is that right or did the man wander off
well i don't know we don't know it's a
mystery handy manual let's find out
yeah uh oh we'll look at it later it
says i guess
it's just showing us in the beginning
you know they don't have like
instruction books for games anymore they
they teach you how to do it through
showing you got it right it's like a
tutorial anyone watching right now
this is gonna get so much better okay
you ever been on a big plane like a big
747 a lot of luggage
full load and it's got to take off from
a runway it rumbles down the runway
and then slowly you just feel it barely
get off the ground
that's where we are right now but we're
gonna get to a part where at like 35
40 000 feet we are soaring you're all
having mimosas in first class
see look this is all this is all
practical uh this is all a practical
set here it's not cool all right here
she is it looks like it was once very
grand
i'll narrate her she just said that she
said it looks like it was once very she
opened the book
oh god this is great if i wanted to open
a book i could just yeah we don't need
to we
don't need to read them okay so she puts
her book away all right so let's we got
to figure out what to do here i
guess these ropes once attached to that
hook
all right here we go how can she do
anything she has no fingers she has two
flesh
circles okay she's grabbed onto the hook
and now wait a minute i have an idea oh
you know what i think i need to get the
stick down here hold on there's a
sticker right here let's go investigate
this stick
right this is good simple problem
solving
man the game just started you know it
could be worlds of exploration you know
we've already lost 15 interns 15
potential interns
people that wanted to sign up and work
for us for free
have now decided they don't want to and
that number will be multiplied
15-fold within the hour uh
somebody's asking if we're going to do
far cry 5 for clueless gamer i don't
know
how to do five oh don't get me started
on what is it called
far cry 5 far cry 5 don't get me started
that's my
jam don't throw shade at tyga far cry it
doesn't make any sense
shut up the tiger thing doesn't make any
sense i love far cry
that's my i'm throwing any shade in
there it's my
jam yo yo it's fine it's all right it's
look it's i'm just trying to get the
stick up on the thing shut up god
listen please it looks pornographic stop
it get out of there
stop it it looks this looks bad okay i'm
sorry
all right so okay i i i wanna before you
have to go i just want to get this
don't touch my hair you can touch my
hair
touch it now pretend these are your
fingers it's virtual
now your fingers go full screen
see that's
in vr you're getting to touch conan's
hair touch my hair in vr
see that see that right there that's
happening in vr
this looks also disgusting someone's
gonna
do some kind of meme with that some kind
of pornographic
gif i know what you kids are up to your
minds are in the gutter
you all need to join the army
immediately all right what's happening
we're we're gonna hit the bell with the
stick what's this
we're hitting the belt look hey look we
have the stick good job
thanks thanks good job there we go so
wait what happened what did the bell do
the bell signaled and then you go up
and then you see look at this you know
what i stayed at this place once it's in
the bahamas
so that's oh i'm lumi i'm trying to find
my granddad this is such
a sad narrative he wanders away a lot
granddad yes
your granddad is the comment and the
aging yeah
how come he isn't being properly cared
for oh we can't afford to
with the health care system the way it
is is he on medication
no we can't get the medication we have
the wrong hmo
oh this is terrible oh well you'll never
see him again
bye oh my god this is a dark world we've
entered
i thought it was a real fun uh uh very
light
uh little uh little narrative but now i
see right beneath the surface is a
bubbling darkness
yeah yeah all right i think we have to
figure out this puzzle
uh which maybe
there we go opened it up little card was
a cardboard uh
little cardboard thing yeah that was a
good thing good thing that you found the
code because you can't get through a
cardboard lock
anytime soon
oh what were some of your uh were some
of the highlights of your of the italy
trip what were some of your favorite
things we went and did and saw
oh my god too much to remember uh lots
of
amazing travels mostly just exposing
jordan for the fraud he is
that was the reason behind the whole
trip was to expose jordan schlansky
who's always pretending to be italian
as just a creep from long island and we
did it
words out ali says uh will you ever come
to romania
what's that will you ever come to
romania for the show we ever shoot a
show in romania
i'd love to yeah yeah no have you ever
been to eastern europe over there no if
not i would love to go to eastern europe
you've got so many places to go and we
will get there we will get there that's
right exactly
uh hold on a second i gotta figure out
what to do okay
um so you're gonna play uh people are
gonna watch you play games that's right
if you're just joining us uh we are
playing uh uh 24 hours of mobile uh
games from the google play store we got
a lot of surprise
guests like this dude you have no idea
how many people
are coming you have no idea who's coming
that's right you don't know what's going
to happen
anything could happen exclusive moving
exclusive music performances
behind the scenes tidbits all sorts of
crazy stuff i think i hate to say it but
i think
everybody has to say goodbye to conan i
think you know what i gotta do i gotta
go
prep today's show that's right i gotta
go prep today's show we gotta get that
going
we're very excited mr martin shorts on
the show today marty shorts on the show
i love him
love martin uh we have a couple of
surprises on tonight's show we're also
taping something in advance it's gonna
be coming out in about a week that's
good too
i think they want me out of here yeah i
think they want me out i think they want
you out all right
it was a a coup that we got you here
thank you everybody says goodbye say
goodbye to conan goodbye everybody
that's right
yes and uh you'll be checking in
throughout the 24 hours yes
i'll be checking in i'm gonna try and
check in every hour i love it that would
be amazing if you could do that
fantastic just gotta go get out of this
sweater okay cool makes sense all right
awesome thank you conan
thanks a lot all right
that's right oh my gosh i've been saying
goodbye please play some dress-up games
i don't know what's a dress-up game
olivia i don't know uh all right so
let's get back to lumio city
actually i kind of want to go back to
monument valley too but let's play some
lumion city first
here we go this game is awesome i feel
like this kind of this game kind of
reminds me of
wallace and gromit did you guys ever see
uh waltzing uh
fantastic the
major chaos the bad man is gone that's
right can you guys see how much i was
sweating
while he was here it was crazy uh that's
right don doll
i love it bye everyone's saying bye bye
no dress-up games i don't know what a
dress-up game is everybody i'm not sure
what that is what you're talking about
all right so let's find our granddad
here um
all right actually let's get somebody
else uh let's get uh my favorite person
in the world beth morosky in here that's
right those of you watching
coco hey friends now beth is with you
guys in the chat so behave yourselves
because she's got a little thing we like
to call the band hammer
just oh is that is that how it works
yeah it just makes it pretty doesn't
make a very loud noise doesn't it it's
pretty quiet yeah it's a very
it's going to be a long 24 hours exactly
over exert myself you know what that's
true yeah it's it's it's more of like a
little rock hammer you use
people think it's a giant light yeah
what was it
away at trolls that's right exactly
that's that's how you get it from the
inside you erode them from the inside
then they collapse
that's right she's too nice to ban
anyone you know what give her
shots sean db 2012. 2012 exactly
uh-oh oh somebody's saying your pants
are up they should pay you more you know
beth gets
that gets paid more than i do so i get
paid nothing because i'm just a ninja
all right
beth what do you think about this game i
like this game it looks beautiful
have you played this game before no i
played the first one the monument valley
but
this is new to me interesting i love it
all right this is gonna be a lot of me
looking confused because there's
very very many puzzles in this game
and by the way for the record for
everybody watching now that conan left
uh that uh that lock puzzle
i tried to do like six times before and
i couldn't do it
so i was a little panicking but i did it
the first time when kelly was here
so i was like super nervous yeah i was
extremely extremely nervous so
uh good lord let beth play you know the
term you see we will let beth play beth
you are going to play later tonight i
have my own block that's right i'm not
even going to be
here 9pm that's right so look out for
the beth block
coming at you at 9pm the old betlock all
right let's figure out what we got to do
here
and anybody who's played this game
please help us because i'm dumb
so what do we have to do
these are switches somehow
who's played this game beth's throwing
it down jack dylan you're right
uh camilo yes of course
get it down uh yes yeah you guys can
request uh games from the google play
store too and we'll try to get to them
yeah we have a ton of games scheduled
but
we'll probably be in there already
mm-hmm
that's right hey disga the king
2k14 thanks for joining us everybody
um so i'm not sure what to do here we
got pluses and minuses
am i supposed to move something around
you have any any idea what to do all
right you know what maybe we got to get
some wire
let's get some wire somewhere yeah and i
say wire because i'm from michigan i say
wire and i say fire
do you have any words that you say oddly
um i say
bubbler look at this game dude this is
insane look how beautiful this is
beautiful
i love it uh let's go up here and see
what's going on
can we climb up here this game is
luminous city
luminos city we're playing we started
off monument valley too yeah which is
also gorgeous we'll get back to that in
a minute
uh but now we're playing oh here we go
i knew it rip it off dude rip it off
hey there's a person down there oh i'm
not strong enough to bend it back myself
we're reading all the way look at this
yeah we read the twitch chat i got you i
got everybody
we got facebook here these are real
models used in the game this is a
these are practical really yeah this is
all it's fantastic
gorgeous wait what does that say seem to
be growing from inside the house
uh we have to go over there
oh you got some love from michigan yeah
michigan love
the ace deuce ann arbor i call it
oh wait a second here we go here we go
look at this look at this i'm going to
put the old hook
on the old thing
and then somehow make it
work we're reading both chats hupato
all the time i want tarya back says
meese4
um can't make this work kona will be
back uh
every hour he's gonna be back every day
in some way or another that's right in
some form or another
walter bees now what's with the ultra
instinct thing is that like something
kids are saying what's the ultra
instinct thing guys somebody tell me i'm
done
that's with it let us know unless it's
something crude oh it's a dragon ball
thing
oh really oh my god dragon ball z great
game
um player unknown's battleground
is not a mobile game flexing somebody
won't be playing it but it is a fun game
well you know what i've been playing
some fortnite that's pretty cool too all
right luna city here i gotta figure out
there's definitely i hooked the thing to
the thing
uh holy chubs i won't say that but oh
hello to indonesia hey hes2 what's going
on
oh one grunts one's grown through the
roof
one's going through the roof what is it
a lemon tree all right
i guess this is me oh hey look at this i
can go inside
oh maybe i can't winch isn't doing
anything with any power we got to get
some power going
now see here was the thing before
i need to find some wire or something to
get the fuse box working
maybe i could do something with the
lemon tree
maybe not let's see here
try to bend the antenna yeah uh jahio321
how do i do that i need to i think to
bend the antenna i have to get the power
going right
but the problem is i don't have any wire
to work with the thing this is
definitely how you do it
let me just start tapping around here
until something works
wheezy max says your eyes are going to
melt after staring 24 hours into that
tiny screen
yeah my eyes are already you know what
joke's on you my eyes are pre-melted
pre-melted from years of video game
playing it's already they're watery and
broken
can you go inside to the door to the
left can i go inside of the door to the
left
this way up here
uh huppito yes it's only mobile games
but there's some crazy good mobile games
it's insane
i gotta say i was never really
we did we did another stream uh which
we'll
be taking a look at the highlights of uh
later tonight but
uh of mobile games and i never really
ventured into the mobile game
world before and i was blown away and
now i've got like 20 of them on my phone
and i'm out of memory so that's cool
yeah uh because they're awesome
uh something's going on with these lemon
trees i feel like first of all if you
have a lemon tree in your house
don't let it grow through the roof
that's that's that's that's a lot of
money garden situation yeah when you get
when you have problems with your roof
that's just it's a it's a it's a money
suck it's just gonna
you know that's one of the biggest
problems in a house a lot of people
think it's the plumbing a lot of
building it's electrical it's the roof
it's lemon trees you know water gets in
water does a lot of damage it's a very
insidious kind of damage
creatures get get in all kinds of
creatures
creepies and crawlies maybe we can go
let's go inside the house
you know what we haven't done gone
inside the house hey who's stupid me
all right we should rename this stream
instead of uh
24-hour mobile marathon electricity oh
look at this
here we go look we found some plans hey
we can make some lemon sauce too
wait is that a real i think that's a
that's a real uh
that's a real recipe that's crazy greet
the zest from one of the lemons and
squeeze out the juice maybe
later tonight we make some
wow this is cool all right somebody's
obsessed with lemons
all right we have the plans
do i need to you know what let's pick
some lemons look at me picking these
lemons
is it stealing if you break into
someone's house and pick their lemons
and then leave is that stealing
if it says like overhang then what about
if the overhang is like also in their
house
tree is a little bit outside so yeah
what about if this tree right here where
i've broken into their house is in their
house and i take something from inside
their house without asking them does
that seem fine
okay cool great just wanted to make sure
old dirty pants this looks like my
apartment minus the lemon trees and all
the cleanliness
uh got the schematic for the power board
here's the question though
can i what am i going to stick lemons on
this power oh look at
well well well what do we have here uh
hi lindsay i still can't do anything hey
miss toots what's up
lemons i'm having fun just
jack is mad i don't know what that means
what tablet is that it's the nvidia
shield tablet it's great um
i'd still think i need some kind of
wires or something right could i should
i try sticking a lemon on here
oh boy oh wait
the lemons do stick on here what what
this game is bananas
or should i say lemon thank you you know
what this game isn't
a lemon oh okay all right i'll high five
that i'll high five that give it up for
bethenny lemon jokes everybody
what's happening oh here you want to
turn up the old volume peru
it's got some nice vibes yeah it's got
great vibes
oh now that conan's gone it's so much
more relaxing in here
and it smells better he smells kind of
like nervous cheese
it smells like lemons oh wait that's
just the screen i'm having a stroke uh
decibel 217. hey thanks for watching
decibel uh yes i would love to hear a
joke as long as it's not dirty or
a lemon thank you i promise i'm gonna
stop making lemon jokes okay
so wait do you think i should maybe try
to put the lemon
here we go wait do i want to put it over
all the pluses or the pluses and minuses
how does electricity work i have no idea
i am not a science i'm not i'm not a
stem
conan's high five is a punch yeah it's a
closed five
cones like didn't we do a great job
closed five
don't put lemons on the double plus all
right
uh okay so
[Music]
maybe we wanna oh you know what we watch
this move
i'm gonna put it on the oh
so maybe i have to do all the pluses and
minuses
oh wait there's something in the bottom
here ah this is so
i'm so bad i'm so bad with math
plus and minus people are saying plus
and minus okay we got to cover all the
pluses and minuses got it
uh like a car battery needs positive to
negative
got it yes
that seems easy i feel dumb
okay all right so all the pluses and
minuses we have to cover with lemons
okay wait that's not gonna work
oh wait here we go i want to put it up
here each plus has a minus
next to it i will say uh points for
originality in this game for sure
of a
okay okay here we go boom
watch me work this lemon
oh come on dude
get on the yes okay
now initially i wouldn't have no i
wouldn't have thought
to put lemons on i mean if this was a
real life
my first instinct is not to use lemons
as a way to complete a circuit board but
then again you know what i did watch a
lot of macgyver as a kid
which i think honestly helps me okay
here we go we did it and they gave us an
extra lemon
it's like when you finish making
furniture and then you're like oh we did
it
it's working now it's gonna smell like
burnt lemons
i knew it that's cute just needed a good
bash
oh that you know what typical situation
man taking a man taking credit for our
work
you know i'm a bit more telling
mansplaining
all right here we go we did it oh
there's one left over you know what we
can make
some of that uh lemon sauce or whatever
cocktail
cocktail sometimes exactly it's five
o'clock somewhere
all right uh when life gives you lemons
you make
you complete a circuit board that's
right aquarium chin 99.
koala's happy mr magic man bye
hey dirty fingers okay here we go you
were right dirty fingers all right so
now we gotta go
that's all fixed now great all right so
let's go up the old
the music picked up let's go inside
yeah here comes phil
sneaking in the side oh my oh the cool
music is too loud hey phil yeah
bastard all right here we go this is
normally where you put the uh
button to a winch is on the outside of a
house where you have to reach around
very
dangerously all right
uh okay we bent the thing
now what oh maybe we go up here oh maybe
we jump you know what i think we get on
the antenna that shoots us over
check out this move yep
i knew it oh yeah let's do it
yes oh this is awesome oh that was so
cool
dude how beautiful is this game oh my
god it looks like the good place tim
looks like the what the town from the
good place oh i haven't watched a good
place
[Music]
oh oh hello uh
all i'm seeing is is the end of a cave
johnson quote and i love cave johnson
from portal 2.
great game great person jk simmons is
amazing used to work out at my gym
uh he's ripped what can i say the dude
is
that's me the mayor's lost cat this game
is so whimsical
we're basically in a wes anderson if wes
anderson made a game it would be this
we are but
all right all right try to grab that cat
uh-oh chase him don't tell me what to do
how about this hi brazil
the cat's just gonna run away uh he
lives with the old mayor
now let me just can i just ask a quick
question
remember our it's our grandpa
disappeared right okay our grandpa now i
don't
want to make any assumptions about the
physical fitness of our grandfather
but to get to this place
we had to take a bunch of lemons stuff
them on a circuit board
go and take a hook bend back an antenna
get on the antenna loose the hook and
fly over a wall to get here
do we really think our grandpa is came
this way
i'm just asking maybe he might have
wandered off
possibly the other direction in the
forest he's just in there like
that's all i'm saying i'm just you know
what i don't mean to tear any any
anything down just you know first rule
of looking for someone who's lost
use common sense you're probably just
making some lemonade probably just yeah
he's probably just making saloon
you know what he probably just went to
the bathroom and then he just came out
of the bed i was like oh where did my
granddaughter go i don't know all right
you know what we're on an adventure
i don't mean to poo poo anything yeah
this is awesome it's
you know a little understand suspension
of disbelief a little
few logic problems when you make the
luminosity lumiocity movie
come to us we'll help you out with the
plateaus all right here we go
all right so let's see here maybe
grandpa yeah uh-huh
grandpa's got moves maybe your grandpa
could do it yan i bet i bet your grandpa
could
um please do a clues game on far cry 5
when it comes out maybe
maybe captain i don't know you know what
i'm going to tell you guys a secret
a lot of clueless gamer stuff is uh
conan's a busy dude so it's about about
getting his time getting his eyes
getting those hands what am i talking
about it's starting to get dirty but uh
it's bugging his attention
you found my little darling thank you
okay i get so worried about the poor
things
and now the power has died again my poor
city your city runs on lemons
all right look at these little kitties
this is a surprising amount of cats yes
it is
you're a fan of conan we work for conan
you're watching the right stream here's
a lemon
i'm gonna give her a lemon your city i
never owned it no no no just took very
good care of it she's the mayor oh
you are the mayor all right cool
okay let's oh wait i was going i wanted
to go downstairs can i go back in
clueless indeed hey matricia what's up
is conan hiring says melanie i think
we're always hiring
we're always hiring and we're never i
was going to put the link in but i
didn't think kind of what
yeah teamcoco.com internships
is the place to go he prefers limes
you know what i think it kind of depends
oh here we go all right
now this is a puzzle i can get behind
i'm more of a gears guy i'm more of a
gears fella here we go
get ready for 16 hours and be trying to
figure this out
oh someone on facebook said the guys who
made coraline should make this movie
oh my god that i agree carline looks
like this
coraline's great creep very creepy great
book
was that written by tim burton it wasn't
was it i think it's like neil gaiman
maybe produced or something
got some more michigan people in the
house now what do you think of me just
randomly putting all these gears on
is this a good idea probably not i feel
like there's got to we have to figure
out like a plan right
yeah just like the circuit board thing
because it's like they have to move
them interconnecting ways or something
right something yeah okay here we go
what about this
oh darn it this one
nope there's got to be oh see this is
the one i'm looking for right here
there we go we got two oh look at this i
don't know
they're all different enough five five
has got to be
you know a sit this is a sixer right
here oh no
no it's gotta hook up to that little one
so it's gotta be a fiber
fiber got it all right
tv is dad lumio i'm not sure what you
mean
um but somehow i agree with you yes
i mean certainly i was raised by the
television if that's how we're doing it
that video games uh that doesn't look
maybe this one oh i see we're not
supposed to use all the pegs oh
tricky tricky mark and ricky that
doesn't make any sense but
okay here we go uh the biggest goes to
the right
can i say manca s yes i can
i just said it mindset uh oh thank you
sir robert stroll we do a spot-on job
with the editing
well well well i'm gonna give it up for
our control room back over there
wait can you guys cut to camera two yeah
look at this we got a control room cam
yes oh look at these guys guys are
making it all go down
that's right oh look at that look at how
look at how
sad and dark it was over in that little
corner i you know it's gonna be fun over
the 24 hour stream to see
uh all the coffee cups yeah we should
just do a time lapse of like
all like the snack wrappers and all that
stuff yeah it's amazing
i love this background by the way give
it up for that this is just like what
yeah
it's a green screen it's a green screen
guys okay here we go yeah did we say
that it's going to change
throughout yeah we've got all sorts of
funky stuff oh man we got so much funky
goodness coming at you
you guys are just joining us uh you're
watching the team coco 24 hour mobile
marathon sponsored by you're almost one
hour in
is that true yeah oh my god wow i think
53.
i think this is gonna fly by it that'll
be really upsetting
it's gonna fly by until about six am
then it's gonna crawl i'm very tired
because i'll be crawling
by that point um i did bring 24
different t-shirts
did you and outfits guys i brought a lot
of matte weird matching outfits
so stay tuned tonight because i'm gonna
start wearing some pretty weird uh weird
clothes it's gonna be great
um i got a shirt that has a bunch of uh
parrots smoking cigarettes and a hat
that matches
oh my gosh yeah i can't even imagine
what that looks like yeah well you're
gonna
see it
where's the jordan robot man he's back
in his uh hyperbaric chamber
until we need him then we pull him out
we activate we
activate the jordan no throwback comment
he's all like dancing taco mentioned
jordan is a lot like the winter soldier
for us we
defrost him every 20 years he goes and
does a mission and then we make him
fight down on a thing in a racist memory
that's right
oh look at this you know once i figured
out i didn't need to use
all the gears it was easy oh but i have
to fill it up over here
all right let's see
it's kind of sounds like bugs
oh it does sound like yeah
oh we're doing oh we only need two more
gears in here but i think this is where
it's gonna get gnarly
oh there we go so close so close
we did it yes tangles tingles
or maybe we should do a gear thing put
our hands like this and like
all right sorry about that look not
every handshake guys can be amazing okay
you just gotta go for it sometimes i
think let's try the gear thing again
ready can we go full screen on this
here let's get so you can get up close
all right we're gonna do a new secret
gear handshake
that's the wrong way whatever which way
should i be going
a puzzle that has gears on it beth and i
will do that so we're never going to do
it again in 24 hours
yeah all right i got a lemon i don't
know what does this thing do over here
there's a lot of cats
it's satisfying to see them all moving
smoothly like that yes it is
what does that do
i got all the cogs moving why would i
want to do that
oh brother all right well let's get out
of here i don't even know what the
oh here something happened over here i
think
oh my god you know what if you're making
a town
don't put puzzles in it just put
like just normal signs of things to do
and how to turn stuff on who's making
this town
don't let wes anderson be a civil
engineer in your town
it's too cutesy he doesn't he makes
great movies but he doesn't get anything
done
oh look at this now we're going to
change a gazebo thing oh here i'm in the
way
sorry gotta this is ridiculous
oh my god wes anderson why did you make
this town like this
solo solo0917 no we're not going to be
on the stream for 24 hours but we will
be here
yeah because we would be dead uh well
that's true mariata says the mayor is a
crazy cat lady with dementia so
that does bring up a good point okay um
all right i'm not exactly sure how this
is
working these all just seem like random
colors to me
because i'm stupid uh
do you see any kind of pattern at all in
this
is it match it kind of is it like a
primary color thing
i don't know it doesn't really match
i can't quite figure it out oh wait wait
wait we're supposed to make oh we're
supposed to make the uh
oh does it look like that yeah
no no that's what changes oh wait no
you're right
to be it like i'm dumb okay uh so wait
let me do this
quickly
you know what's hilarious it uh is we're
doing a 24-hour stream and we don't have
a working clock
isn't it awesome and i feel better it's
kind of better sometimes
uh it is 12 55. i have 12 58
are you have 12 58 oh 12 25 no all our
clocks are all our clocks are wrong
uh okay hold on all right so
uh okay we got that set let me just
change this one
uh mindset who knows keep watching
play nova 3 all right we'll take a look
we'll uh
take a peek at it there's a photo
beneath the controls great great okay
right so i'm trying to get that one set
i've never been great with um
colors wait okay all right i think i got
that set i just need to get the bottom
one
oh snap
did i do it didn't i do it
doesn't that seem right to you no wait
wait we just need to match whatever's in
the middle
i think hey can you put us on the left
can you hey can you put us on the other
side
of the screen thanks i don't uh
that's red orange what do you mean i
want red blue
red orange red orange i want red
blue there you go wait all right so
there's the thing we're trying to do
over there
wait red orange i just want to solve
this puzzle all i want to do is solve
this puzzle
uh maybe erin wallace you never know
um i can't quite
are you guys whispering how to do it
over there if you know how to do it tell
me what to do
clockwise the middle clockwise all right
wait let's leave it there okay now
rotate the outer one
counter like that
yeah one more time
come on it's not right is it is it not
no
it's not quite right but it's closed oh
wait this is going to take a while lucas
don't worry we give up easy don't worry
lucas
oh wait i'll wait okay
the middle one the no no the outer one
the top of the outer one has to be
orange okay wait okay wait and now
now wait hold on a second do we need to
wait wait
i got it now i got it now there's
another red hold on a lot and then that
one
needs to get blue and then dark blue
so wait that has to be oh no wait so
this one's upside down
okay blue then dark blue and then
the center needs to be guys i'm in the
zone right now
i'm in the effing zone hold on please
oh no wait this one boom
right does that look great
no no no no no wait oh no no it's
falling apart
wait this need hold on once i'm sorry
i'm changing the inner one i'm changing
up bardo i'm changing it
we're so close guys it just needs to be
red
oh wait i think it needs to is there
another red
is this not right okay here all right
look at this red one here we go red
orange
yeah that's right isn't it right
nailed it oh my gosh we did it oh my god
that's incredible oh look at this stairs
listen we jumped there before and dude
there are stairs right above
us look why don't we just take these
stairs ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous all right uh you
know what we'll go down here just
just for funsies all right
and we walk up and wow nothing's gonna
happen oh okay oh no we're over here
all right great uh all right it's one
o'clock uh i think it's time to uh
to check in uh with the host of uh the
host of the show
yeah mr conan o'brien i think it's time
uh to check in with him
well it's 1pm that means that you've
hung in there for an hour
or you're just checking in now in which
case i don't respect you
either way it doesn't matter it's 1 pm
probably getting near lunchtime you
either have eaten
or you're probably about to eat
now here's what i think i hope you had a
good breakfast i
say get some protein get some good
protein
at lunch time all right and uh make sure
that you have a salad too
and then um that should handle it that's
my advice for now
i would say protein some kind of salad
you can have bread if you want
i mean i'm fine with gluten but mostly
you should be thinking about lunch or
you've already had lunch hey watch out
for the processed foods
unless they uh buy advertising on our
show and then stuff them in your kneed
hole
fast and hard okay
came out weird one o'clock i'll see you
soon
welcome back everyone to the 24 hour
mobile marathon sponsored by google play
thanks conan that was so great a little
uh little dietary
little dietary advice that was fantastic
and uh
i'm very excited uh to welcome our next
guest he's the music book for our show
he's got one of the coolest beards i've
ever seen
mr rock and roll himself please welcome
roy herschkovitz troy hurst
let's get on in here look at you oh
comes in comes in look at that you can
see a green screen behind us amazing
uh welcome roy hi say hi to the chat say
hi to twitch facebook and youtube
oh my god you're all here yeah look at
now look we have a cool castle behind us
perfect that's because we're going to be
playing a a
a little game called game of thrones
conquest
which is super fun um
and i think uh i wanted to start with
the tutorial here
oh because i have no idea episode of
game of thrones you need a tutorial i've
never
i've never played this game in my life
but i'm very excited too
uh okay we don't need to do okay okay we
don't need to
okay okay we don't need to okay that's
good that's good uh introduce yourself
in the chat tell them what you do on the
show hi folks
uh roy hershkowitz i'm the music booker
i booked the bands that play on the show
conan on tbs and uh that's what i do
that's what you do with this guy you for
20 years listen to a lot of music
i do take us through take us through a
day in uh the life of robbie hirschkivet
and
a day where you work i don't we don't
care what you do outside of work we want
to know what you do
i mean we do care we're gonna be with
you for a whole hour so you're gonna
we're gonna get into it for sure but
explain to the people
well on a band-aid we start with uh
music that's the first thing we rehearse
when we have a band play the show
so we load in the bands we have
uh sound check we rehearse them and then
i go upstairs to my office where i
uh answer emails uh about
bands mostly and try to listen to music
hopefully and then we come down and do a
show at 4 30 and then i go home around
six that's the
that's the second version of it that's
the day that's the cycle that i've been
that's the cycle uh so you watch game of
thrones right
i do watch games oh yes my man but like
i was saying i always need a tutorial
like every time a season starts i need a
recap i can never remember what's going
on
anytime somebody's like so and so from
house baratheon and then i have to go
look up which one's house baratheon
it was the robert's rebellion and it
started the whole game of thrones
situation i think we want to build all
of that i think we want to build our
house banner right now
sweet all right let's build our house
banner i don't know what that
oh let's we're going to build our hop
you know you do this
he does look like rasputin oh good lord
uh i like the fiery eyeballs yeah i look
fiery obviously wicked yeah
the uh fiery eyeball man all right yeah
the different
what do you got you got uh oh you think
that's a white walker lannister
uh no they they're they're they're the
land of ice and snow they're not the
fiery guys
i swear i watch every episode i have no
idea what's going on on this show
it's look i study it like the talmud and
i have no idea what's happening
here's the thing here's what i like
about game of thrones there's a lot i
like about it first of all
it's a beautiful show very well acted
well written production design's amazing
all that stuff is fantastic
the story a lot of people say is kind of
the idea that what happens after happily
ever after
because the whole thing is uh uh
a robber the the mad king tried to kill
a bunch of people
and then robert had a rebellion and then
jamie
uh kingslayer killed the king and then
this is kind of what happens
after the the happily ever after story
right
guys am i getting this right you're
wrong no yes
uh ooh mariana what's the game you work
on
also they gave me this look at this we
had these cool little stickers made
there well conan stickers fantastic
uh i didn't switch drinks they put this
in a in a cup for me
uh that had conan on it because
that's the show we worked for our banner
has been completed
oh wow well done it's uh a dude who
needs eye drops
that's me after wearing my contacts for
success it's jennifer aniston
uh i know you play dude you play okay
all right so i think we're creating uh
we're creating a a kingdom here man just
follow what tyrion says so build a
stable so hit the button there build a
stable
choose a building spoiler it's game of
thrones i'm saying this stuff that
happened before game of thrones
started that's not a spoiler the fact
the mad king
jamie lannister is called the king
slayer in the very first episode because
he's already killed
the match spoilers if like it's been on
for 20
years it's you're like months after the
last season ended exactly perhaps
i'm not gonna hand right i'm not gonna
say what happened you know
in terms of uh the last season but uh
there's a year between seasons you're
not allowed to call spoiler alert
by the way what is the rule on spoilers
like what's how many months
proper etiquette i think after the first
like
you give it a week or two and then after
that you go two weeks
and then you go that's hard you initiate
by going hey did you see game of thrones
oh okay so you like you gotta
you can't just launch into you gotta
sort of give a courtesy heads-up yeah
that's true yeah i i do love that
simpsons where uh
what is it uh homer comes out of the
theater after seeing empire strikes back
is like
vader's luke's father and everybody just
the whole
line i have i've never killed dumbledore
there's two kids and like my i find my
job with my five-year-old is to not let
him
find out that vader until he watches the
movie so anytime like a star wars
conversation starts
up i love it i'm pretty i'm like trying
to pretend i love just so he can hear
buffs
no spoilers dudes that only came out in
19 you know
you don't care about that swear words
you don't care about this if you just
care about star wars are fine i love it
i think you got to build unfortunately
or
or spend one gold spend one gold okay i
mean you can
yeah there we go you know you do you man
yeah this is your kingdom
construction complete we just made a
stable so that's cool now what do i do
uh rosebud was the sled jon snow's alive
your promised cheez-its i wasn't
promised cheez-its
build a stable what's my phone number oh
man you don't want my phone number i
don't know what i just did
um you're building a stable bro so this
is kind of i think this is a little bit
like sim city in terms of this is like
we're building a
a world a kingdom and then they're going
to try to fight us or like starcraft
i haven't played simcity since 1994.
uh um i'm just going to keep pressing
buttons to move this forward i feel like
that's
yeah i should do i think you should i
think you should no spoilers somebody
said ooh
uh what what am i upgrading i don't know
build a training yard okay i can't wait
for hour fives
it's still me trying to build a house
wait i had someone screaming me in a
comment section of an article because i
spoiled enterprise
eight years after it had ended what's
the end of enterprise
spoil it for me i don't care i'm not
gonna watch it yeah that's not
that's not a thing yeah you can't you're
not allowed to do that
uh construction's coming you're making a
training yard
look at that you're building a really
beautiful kingdom great i'm just
pressing buttons to move this forward
now let's say you were
the head of a kingdom uh in westeros
would you rule with an iron fist
or would you be more like diplomatic and
uh like uh you know like uh
like a guy i think i would give the
sorry i interrupted no go ahead the
false illusion of like diplomacy
oh no everybody's like oh he's the good
king he's the kind king
and then like right when somebody starts
[ __ ] with me like you just find him
like splayed on a thing yeah he's dong
cut off and he's oh everybody's boy
okay all right and then like nobody
messes with me and then i go back to
being like
hey what's up guys wow free it's taco
tuesday you're like the joker yeah
basically like the joker uh
oh they killed the engineer toy pull and
archer a couple
okay cool um
oh boy i i really don't know you're
doing a great job
just upgrade to a level two keep you're
doing a great job and i'll take over if
you want if you want to talk to the chat
it's up to you
waiting for conan to turn critical he'll
come back before you know it he'll be
i've got bricks
bricks poison heart 77 not only did you
not miss this week's stream
it we're doing it until noon tomorrow
the same stream so
there's a lot of stream to watch it's
going to look like this tomorrow
but blaze is going to be destroyed i'll
destroy now dizzy that says my friend's
kid like phantom menace more than the
original trilogy
how old was the kid to be fair yeah
because
to be fair phantom menace darth maul is
dope
darth maul is great it's it's really for
the kids because it's a pod race and
it's about a kid it's true but it's a
completely disposable movie
yeah i'd like to see darth like i'd like
to see the lore of darth maul after
because theoretically
you know being chopped in half and
falling down a giant shoot does not mean
you're dead
sure in the world of star wars of course
not you can live on after that as you
as darth maul does as he does and then
in star wars rebels now
so i'm gonna say you know what's one
thing
everybody thought the plot of phantom
menace they didn't like it
honestly what bothered me the most was
the sound of the pods
during the race really that i didn't
like it that's what probably because it
was like
if you go we can't play it because of
rights issues but i'm going to do a
little impression of it which is
uh it was like it was like
oh yeah solid impression
it didn't sound like they're going fast
it just sounded like my
grandparents car like their old like
but they were very junky if you think
about it i know but it just didn't
i mean you need that like sound wise
i mean look i get it it's pots not
everything has to be so alien george
lucas
all right darth maul has only got five
lines yeah non-castus that's right
and that's how you make by the way an
amazing uh mysterious character boba
fett
great example only had like a couple
sure you know
um
how are we doing on this old oh baelish
peter baelish
that guy by the way great in the wire oh
he's so good so good by the way good so
good in the dark knight too
great and dark knight great great in the
wire i only caught
in the uh the dark knight and the i know
and and uh
i feel like i can't batman rises i can't
talk about what happened to him
in uh game of thrones or can i where are
we on spoilers with bayley
all right but uh where are we on okay
my flight plan only has
room for two of you
in the beginning with bain this is the
opening scene he's that's right
a lot of loyalty for a hired gun or
perhaps he's wondering why someone would
shoot a man
before throwing him out of a plane is
that is that a good impression oh
brother
i don't know i don't think it's good
that my bane impression inspires
laughter
you do good babe you have a good bane i
we talked about it because
i sound more like the guy from
masterpiece theater are you building
this kingdom
oh i don't know what it is what was the
voice of bane like
uh in the trailer remember they changed
the voice i watched that a lot by the
way there's a couple there's only a
couple you i watch
youtube clips on youtube over and over
and over and over there's like five
clips right now i'm obsessed with on
youtube
and one of them is baine's original
voice what does it sound like
it sounds you know what it sounds like
and back me up on this chat back me up
in this sounds more calm
he just sounds completely like like
unperturbed about anything which is like
super evil
i think of him as sounding so calm that
it's menacing yeah that's what it is
right but
it's even more like you know with the
initialism because lottery says it is
kind of
it is kind of sean connery it is it's
very that
boar's den oh look at this giant board
by the way it kind of looks like me
let's get in there how close do a boar
do i look like
look at that i think you know what a
boar looks like no go back to the thing
i was showing what a bore looks like
nice trial valley look at that look at
that
what do you think roy good or bad this
is this should be like my dating profile
like my bubble profile
perfect you know pretty good yeah pretty
good that's why i'm single looking like
a stop
filing your bottom face i got a good
boar face and it'll look uh i gotta get
ladies if you love bores call up old
blay
board face uh okay uh we're gonna attack
man right defeat this enemy to earn
prestige and other rewards attack
okay oh we're gonna who we're gonna
select our
we have the militia sounds good
okay finally kill this dumb bore
has all this been so we could build a
fort and kill a boar yeah oh
look how slow we're moving oh my god no
that little piece is us that's why this
thing is 24 hours
it's gonna take us 24 hours to get to
this bore look at how slow we're moving
this piece oh i see what's happening
this is great
uh play your beautiful thing let's go
back to doing bait impressions
yeah exactly perhaps the boy's wondering
why'd he
snort a man cause i'm throwing him out
of a plane
what's the name of that guy the guy who
plays bane oh block link says huppito
all right we'll get into it we'll block
people's links tom hardy i guess we can
do that i like it
great dunkirk great movie amazing
another mask
did you see taboo i saw it wrote that
with his father i love that
who wrote that one who's the slowest the
characters travel in the early seasons
yeah
who wrote taboo uh tom hardy he wrote
taboo yeah he like yeah he created it
with his dad i don't think maybe he
didn't write it he created
this guy dying
you are dying not going to last 24 hours
[Music]
um who knows one thing that i love about
conan
and one thing i love about our show and
one thing that that you do is
um you put a spotlight on bands uh up
and coming bands
okay i leaned out of frame professional
this guy's a professional he you
so what do you like what do you how do
you do that like what do you look for in
a band how do you program the show
what is that process like um what kind
of bands
uh do you like um you know
that's a great place to start how does
it work what i personally like doesn't
always have to match up
with what we're doing on the show i
think that the show has its own sort of
sensibility
based on our audience a little bit on on
conan a little bit on what we've done in
the past
that we sort of have like a sensibility
all of our own and part of that is
mixing that up yeah and sometimes
it's something that intersects with
something i might like or conan might
like but a lot of times we're just
trying to find
uh good stuff and a variety of stuff and
a variety of stuff
yeah and then like always trying to
listen to new stuff filter out new stuff
a lot of stuff that gets pitched into
the show and you just try to
i don't know find fresh stuff dope jams
it's the search for dope jams always
dude it's a never-ending dope jam
scavenge do you now have you ever been
foraging for dope four jeep or dump
hands
yeah um and yeah what are some of the
bands we've had on recently that you
were super excited about
uh every band that we've had i'm trying
to remember like the last i'm gonna tell
you a band that i'd never heard of thank
you because here's
here's one thing is they always uh
mostly our band soundcheck in the
morning yeah so when we get in
you know we always have a production
meeting at 10 o'clock at 10 a.m
and when we get in uh the bands are
already sound checking so we'll turn on
that we all have a feed in our office
that we can watch
what's going on on stage and we'll see
what band is there that day
and this band uh i think they were on
last week uh sophie tucker
yeah never heard of them yeah and i
always love when bands
uh uh bring some bring some of their
product bring a production bring some
production to our stage
and silvie tucker had these risers which
were super cool
now i never thought of this before but
the next time i play
on television yeah with my band uh um
uh uh blair and the blaine
i know whatever it is uh uh dj blay
better uh how about that um the cobras
we were in a rap group called the cobras
uh though we recorded an album
yeah don't look it up and you can't find
it anyway
they had all these risers and i was like
that's so cool because then they got
they were like
there's only two of them i was so smart
because as a duo you got to do something
extra
yeah so that's a band i saw at outside
lands
uh i think last year and that's the fun
thing about
being in my job and getting to go to
music festivals is that you meander
around
and look at are you doing a boring
impression no i'm doing a bear do you
think more like a bear
boar i mean a bear
i think i think i was bored i think i've
got more of a boring mouth
you know uh we are really outside a
castle actually
it's hilarious great question freezing
great question
okay um i want ale
i'm gonna march over uh super slowly and
uh try to kill this bear here i go
10 hours later great
maybe you're creeping this is the most
lackadaisical
maybe you're trying to arms right how am
i supposed to
right all i'm doing is fighting boars
and bears somebody said something about
you can pay to skip the
weight it didn't give me the option we
don't have any gold so uh
stop blocking the guy i'm studying his
magnificent beard
this is a lot of product let's talk
about this because a lot of problems how
long
this is uh over a year and a half over a
year and a half wow
and at what point were you like i'm
doing it
at what point did the commitment come in
every time because every couple years
it was it wasn't this ridiculous and
every couple years i take it down or
take it off
and the last time i did i was not happy
with what i saw
oh no so i just i just was like ah i
don't like
i don't like this god i hate my chin i
don't like what's under here
uh so oh here we go i just stopped uh i
stopped trimming here comes dude here
comes the epic battle between us and
this bear
oh oh my god look at that huge sword we
dude we just
wait we had a huge victory and we killed
that bear hey look at this dude
right here let's kill this guy wait can
we kill this dude
oh tribesman uh oh level four i don't
know if we're ready for this
do we do it i say push on absolutely
push wait push on
because i attacked him yes that's what i
mean oh wait we have to add
march slots whatever that means um it is
you know lumio
it's uh it is amazing how far games have
come it's incredible
aaron wallace plays acoustic guitar
aaron wallace what are some of the songs
you've written
i'll tell you one that i've written uh
unspoken promises
you want to hear it bro you want to hear
uh can i audition to be on the show
right now with my
please please
[Music]
okay by the way it doesn't have any
lyrics it's fine and it's too
it's too instrumental that sounds the
radio edits two hours long that sounds
so
fun yeah maybe you know me i'll play for
you off camera it's just it's going to
be good
i gotta warm up it's a whole but
unspoken promises from my album
said and then uh unsaid in parentheses
said unsaid
i think you should just workshop that a
little a little bit it's something i
believe in it's close to my heart
uh-huh okay hey look we're at the
maesters tower everybody
okay i love the maesters i'm fascinated
by the maesters and game
i think they're all full of uh
i think they're all just a bunch of
hoity-toity hoity-toity
but there's up in their little towers
there's some magic and mystery
and then there was the old guy who was
like yeah and then
he's like doing jumping jacks in his
room look nobody wanted
to heal what it what's his face you know
what's his face with the
ray scale what's his face what am i
talking about the guy with the who the
grayscale and then sam was like no man
i got your back yeah and then by the way
all it take took to heal the grayscale
spoiler alert so earmuffs anybody out
there oh which is basically just prying
it off
like like and then put oatmeal on it
yeah they just put ointment on it they
put
oatmeal yeah yeah you could throw up off
camera
just vomit over there you did before so
we only have one spot to clean up
but no it was so dumb like they're like
this is on
uh this is nobody can heal this
grayscale you're poisoned forever
and and then the guy's just like wink
oatmeal and he's fine
and then he goes back to the tree he
takes him back again yeah
he's totally fine that's a weird what a
bunch of bs
maesters they're talking about jorah
mormont
get it together jorah thank you thank
you handsome dude by the way jorah
mormont handsome only against a real man
that's a real man they're taking that
stuff because he was super skilled he's
not super skilled he just peeled it off
wait no he who's not super skilled sam
sam's the ultimate all he did was he
just read a book
well he read like a he read like a lot
of books he's very smart
he read a couple books and then he made
some oatmeal
probably instant it wasn't even probably
a regular so is sam a wizard like are
the
are the maestros like wizard lights
they're they're a bunch of
it's there it's basically a glorified
book club
it's basically oh let's get together and
read like open spaces with you anymore
i'm just telling it like it is out here
hard truths
hashtag hard truths with play that's my
that's my new album hard truths
all right members of an allegiance game
benefits from seats of power blah blah
blah
ooh look at this person with a cool kid
killed he killed a white walker kill the
one this dude did sam
he did sam tara jason with his dragon
glass
give the guy some credit you know what i
do like sam
what here's what i'm saying sam is
better than the rest of the maesters
okay
he's not a master yet though look at
this guy charles wieder
oh pretty obvious he's just a man with a
specific set of skills his banner is
just wheat
that's a little on the nose nick charles
hey chuck chuck weeder
chuck weirder yeah they could have done
it i could have done better this is a
character that got added at the last
moment
all right yeah totally they were like
somebody looks out the window
wheat all right we gotta find some seats
of power man bayless sure talks a lot
all right iron throne okay so
which uh which seat of power we want to
go for there uh
i mean do we go all the way to the top
because we're short on time or
dude we're not short on time by the way
uh sam is a hotter woman than me correct
because i look like a boar
i have a boar face and i i am alone and
will be forever for the rest of my life
i'm gonna go to the north
go north man the north oh god
oh fun fact bran daler the drummer from
mastodon was a white walker
that's right that's true and uh i talked
to what's the guy
oh man who were the guys who created
game of thrones uh
not created but they wrote it for tv
because it's not george rr martin it's
um
the two dudes i talked to the one guy oh
what's his name oh i'm such a jerk and i
talked to him at comic con they were on
the show
and we talked about mastodon and it was
great uh he was wearing a mastodon game
of thrones shirt and i got to talk to
him i don't even know his name because
i'm uh
the worst person ever if i press
winterfell is that me making an alliance
with winterfell or attacking i don't
want to i don't know
i honestly don't know i haven't been
paying attention because baelish says so
much stuff
i haven't spoiled the whole show don't
worry
oh i think i'm attacking plant lab
plates slow i am a mastermind fan
i think you gotta press one of those
view on map or seats of power view on
map maybe
because i think we have to spoiler alert
march for 26 hours
david benihoff no the other guy the
other guy not david
weiss yes tv weiss that's it i talked to
him he's a very cool guy
they're both very cool tz
glad you can make it we're glad you make
it scout maybe
ice rally or attack super nice guy
should we scout first that seems so good
i think so i think you want to see
what's out there before you get out oh i
can't scout
i can have information rally or attack
information rally or attack uh don't you
rally then attack okay yeah you go round
your troops then you attack well sona be
playing
on negro uh oh well played well played
uh mr cheese
um sona will be playing uh
very soon very shortly i think i don't
have the thing in front of me but very
she's gonna be coming quick mr deck
hi i've escaped the game uh i'm there oh
well done well done i got you back i got
you back i got you back
right here
we have to kill a bear again yay oh man
this is not a bore
here's my question where do you guys go
through music where should i be going to
check out fresh dope tunes spotify
playlists you recommend
youtube mixes you guys like where what
station on
siriusxm where do you go to mine
i don't know sean i don't know uh sona
he's coming up sona's coming up so get
ready
uh i don't know okay here we go here we
go you're back we're back
you're ready to build the tower build
the tavern by the way tavern one of the
most important parts because
being a leader is all about uh uh you
know
leading the people and making the people
happy so it's important that you do that
bring her now well well well plexing
aren't we aren't we
uh uh pretty demanding maybe i will
maybe i won't
yes madeleine at some point heard you'll
be here oh car park records has some
good stuff
there we go oh all good stuff hope you
have a smooth stream thank you
uh mr dude or miss dude
splintered x we're gonna do some more
close gamers so don't worry about that
okay
i've trained we've trained you're you're
ready to march on the north
how do i is sam the author of ice and
fire i don't you know what that's a good
question
maybe he is i don't know wait huh what's
ice and fire
well technically game of thrones is
called a song of ice and fire
this is what i'm talking about too much
time growing up this beer not enough
time
reading some nerdy books like me no idea
what's going on
uh doodad uh we're gonna play another
game at the top of the
hour coming up at two
to two o'clock more spoilers is up until
go to the wikipedia page
i'm tired of people yelling at me for
spoiling stuff but you know what i'll
spoil some others
we're gonna build a tavern uh some other
stuff spoiler alert i'm probably going
to have about 20 coffees
what is your game plan for getting
through the next 20 something hours
a lot of weeping uh you know what keeps
you awake food weirdly
have you planned your meals this is a
great have you seen the movie gi jane
because i'm about to spoil it for you
there's a point in gi jane where demi
moore amazing in an amazing role with
viggo mortensen ya boy vigo
also known as aragorn florida yep all
day i could do this anyway
uh nobody believes it to me more nobody
believes she can you know uh
uh kick everybody's butt they went for
her to ring the bell they're waiting for
her to ring the bell which is
uh i think it's a navy seal or army
range i can't remember what she's quite
training for but it's something
incredibly elite and
uh during training they're waiting for
her to ring the bell and so one of the
things they do it's very sneaky
one of the things that the the people uh
testing these recruits
do is they have them uh uh it's raining
outside it's very cold they have them
come into a classroom
and write down something like their
favorite whatever like why i want to be
whatever that's something dumb it
doesn't matter but
and they turn up the heat and so
everybody falls asleep
except to be more super smart
she had the idea before that they feed
everybody a lot you know and then they
put them in a hot room they fall asleep
she stole a bunch of biscuits or dinner
rolls
some kind of bread or carb situation
stuffed it in her old shirt
then when she starts falling asleep she
goes no i'm not going to fall asleep she
doesn't say that because she's a better
actress than i am
and she goes she pulls out the general
she goes ah she starts eating it that
keeps her awake and she keeps writing
she's the only one awake in the class
that's right
she grows a badass and then they go on
this crazy mission
and viggo mortensen has been a super
like raging
uh mean dude to her uh like she's to
save everybody and it's awesome
really badass it's a great movie uh okay
i'm pretty sure it's like ridley scott
or somebody directly i've just been
retraining
the same squier i thought you were
taking over three days i know how to get
back up there doing i think i'm supposed
to report god we're
not going to say report that we killed a
bear by pigeon
we haven't even taken over one kingdom i
need to
i think i need to i killed a bear what
have you done built a tavern
oh more meat oh yes sir come on man
you got to play in your meetings dude
you win or you die it's game of thrones
bro
i s i just don't know how to get back
coffee kill said spoilered me i'm gonna
get you back dude gij came out like 96.
creature found what other spoilers can
we expect in the spoiler stream oh just
wait
i've seen so many movies so somebody so
much spoiling
well kramer be on the stream yes he will
freight man and i love uh kramer how you
came up with the handle frank man to ask
if you're gonna be on the stream later
well done well done i think that's cute
crames
i'm gonna kill a boar
you mean like i did two hours ago good
lord man oh my god
oh god you started marching this is on
you bro nine hours of marching
oh this is a long march kill the
lannisters
we don't even we can't even find the
lannisters oh wait these are other
houses is that what these are
i don't know man i don't i'm not sure i
can attack this house
why am i yelling lily guy i don't know
i'm very well details what house is this
conan was here and he'll be back
throughout the stream
in one way or another finally some sweet
some more sweet bore action
a good ruler keeps her subjects
entertained that's correct bread and
circuses right isn't that what they say
i mean
i'm just figuring out how this works
these are the houses we can attack them
you can't take a kingdom in your level
hashtag rookie says killjoy malfoy oh
you gotta follow
malfoy you know what's right over here
conan's gum
i'm just gonna i was wondering about
that that's gross don't chew that don't
put that in i'm not gonna cheat i'm not
gonna chew it
because i don't want what he has but
there it is right there guys we're gonna
keep this for all 24 hours
that's my glitch to you who's that dude
it's going right here on this table
everyone off camera is saying how gross
that is mercenary
everybody off camera is saying that i
got excited go to bro
we're going to attack the mercenary camp
and we go to the maestas tower
i dare you to say your name correctly i
can't sing i can't say your name
correctly i'm sorry i don't want to ruin
it
um your favorite album from pink floyd
ooh
i like animals uh i mean i hate to be
obvious but i i the one i listen to the
most is dark side
it's great it's a masterpiece any color
any color you like is the song
i'm a big uh hi-fi uh gear nerd
i'm going into tech and speakers and
amps and all that stuff
and so i have a list of songs and any
color color you like
from dark side of the moon is one of the
five songs that i use to owe
his testimony test out speaker systems
why could a good low end get high-end
it's just because it's dynamic range
most important thank you sorry most
important i know it really well
so like you it's you you always take a
song you're super familiar with
uh how is that your karaoke go-to no
it's uh dr john is my karaoke pyramids
uh it's just i know it really well it's
well recorded and
uh that's why oh awesome and then i and
then second to that i don't think i
played this
for you but i have a like a a 5
1 version of it where like the whole
song goes around the room
it's insane sorry i'm nerding out too
hard no i love this this is great but i
could talk about this for hours
let me have 23 hours to talk about
stereo do we
because we just push you on a camera
over here
i have a quick question as somebody
who's uh not an audiophile and maybe for
the people out there
yeah now when i'm buying a cord
is great when you're buying a what a
cord some kind of cord any kind of cool
yeah
is it important that i get like one of
those gold chords hey tony maggie
is that just a rip off like an 18 gold
braided chord or can i get a cheaper
chord
is a chord a chord i'll tr a chord is a
chord i'll try to give you a short
answer it's all about
diminishing returns and like
being equivalent to your system so like
the equivalent to my system yeah
meaning if you bought a
honda accord you wouldn't put maserati
uh engine parts in there
because that would be crazy right it
wouldn't be balanced does that make
sense to you
so like you wouldn't have if you were
gonna say like hey man i know what
you're getting at
should i buy this ten dollar cord or
should i buy this hundred dollar cord
i'd say what's the rest of your system
look like
if it's a fisher-price system or you
know like
then then sure get yourself a 10 cord
but you can't have like
you know a thousand dollar amp and then
put a 10 cord on it because
i will strangle you got it so what
you're saying i know you're getting at
which is my system
is crappy and so uh
since i spent 300 on three cords you're
saying that was a bad investment
uh well i mean it's only three bucks so
it's hardly an investment
fair enough fair enough your signal
is only as strong as your weakest link
that's going to be on your tombstone is
that your signal is only
already dead yeah uh i'm just upgrading
our stables and stuff
i don't know how to kill more boars but
i'd like to
um okay level three what a great
question what's your favorite radiohead
album ooh how do you pick one favorite
i mean oh goodness is it boring to say
okay computer what's paranoid
uh paranoid androids on okay computer i
mean the benz is
i love the benz uh amazing rock album
not like the rest of radio right right
[Music]
fake plastic trees great whatever the
first song
on there is awesome and crazy airbag
airbag no no no that's uh oh man i'm
gonna have to look at the track lizzy
but it's great i love the benz is one of
my favorite rock albums of all time oh
god what happened
i said just ice on the ground um what
what album do you listen to that's the
see for me that's the thing like what um
do you listen to the most i probably
listen to kid a the most
oh really yeah why did you make that
face
did i make a face i guess i did did i
you know because i just thought i'm like
[Music]
when i think of kid i just got like
it's my radiohead impression jordan
schlansky playing i was late today
because jordan schlansky was asking me
about vinyl on my way here brother
i'm shocked he doesn't know about
violence no he doesn't
who digitize their records hey guys you
want to talk about digital no we don't
well when you're digitizing
uh i'm just gonna do whatever tyrion
lannister tells me to do yeah
do it upgrade to a level two watch tower
okay claim
i i just want to keep pressing buttons
to try to move this forward
um by the way you know we did a clueless
gamer with uh uh
peter dinklage and lena heady peter
negligence
the softest hands of anyone i've ever
felt it's got really soft
beautiful hands it's incredible also one
of the funniest people i've ever met in
my life he's so funny
um dude it's hilarious
okay we have a city the gut guys the gum
is fine the gum is over here on the
table don't touch the gum is fine you
want to just give it a quick chew
what about if we have every guest on the
stream take a chew of the gum
i think someone just that was the
correct response yes
quick community gum chew everybody no
chew stream anyone has that ever been
done before what's going on right here
i don't know sawmill we got wood
um we got what
i heard that the gum is one of the
giveaway prizes
says america's live uh it's really weird
dude up
i'm a weird dude who looks like a boar
by the way
um level two city wall i want more how
do we attack
claim it let's figure out how to attack
i'm tired of not how do i get to the map
that lets me go to other places uh you
were just yeah there we go all right
let's look around
let's get out of this dumb thing can we
do okay there we go
yup this is this is all my city oh can
we attack your city
this is going to get out of our city hit
that weird glowing
gyroscope thing thank you am i going to
get
a weird disease if i keep touching my
face can i attack that guy
yes you can please attack him the
mercenary can't
attack he's got march terrible
club march oh
all right there's a bear over here no no
no wait what about the goblin there's a
goblin guy
oh it says we have to be like yeah we
gotta be level five
what about uh weaker creatures what are
these houses around are there any just
like
mall rats you know any just like uh
oh we're back here um
i guess i'm kind of rodent like myself
temple guardian you're kind of a rodent
i i think we i'm more of a boar i think
you know not a bear because that's cool
because bears are dancing here's a level
two house really snorty
uh i got big tusks uh i know i'm we're
trying to raise you we're trying to kill
something it's
gingerbread ginger vitus says dizzy
death well played
best chuck on the stream so far we're
going to attack a house
jordan could beat the goblin jordan is
the goblin
target shielded what you're attacking a
house
man you cray but i like it i like where
you're going with it let's do it
we got a castle behind us this is dope
i'm going to attack this
oh another boar do it do you know what
you got to get a couple boars under your
belt
i've always said that
team coco send their regards wait we're
team coco we send our regards to you
a polar bear this this is this country's
to are we walking
slowly towards the thing uh let's see i
have no idea where we are oh
mexico up in here yeah mexico wait we're
just a house
that's not moving i don't oh there we
are there we go yep there we go
squeak also i would i love if the set if
there were like sound effects like
like a squeaky like if you were to drag
a giant wooden thing across like a
marble floor like
as you go through the uh everyone's
tuning out of the stream with me making
that noise
old dude's in pain just me trying to get
out of bed in the morning that's what
bane sounds like when he stubs his toe
i didn't know you moved the dress up you
know what's interesting is i went uh
drinking with hunter s thompson when i
was much younger
and he what did you just say yeah he was
when he was on the show frank made me go
to a uh
thing it was me the stream made you go
to a thing yeah he was like i'm not
gonna go
but you have to go and i was like yeah
so uh it was me hunter s thompson the
strokes and lou reed
this is a true story this happened it's
really weird and hunter came into the
room and he kept making these weird
screeching he would like be totally cool
and then
once a while i'll just be like and you
would be like him like
like getting angry at something it was
amazing
incredible he had these huge spike
gloves on he was the nicest dude ever
so cool hat hats sunglasses sunglasses
thing uh uh like a
swiney shirt um yeah and like fingerless
gloves with spikes on them
fingerless gloves what was he drinking
that's a good uh
booze i won't say what kind but um it
was great
really cool really nice dude hey you
talked it was i mean
and then we killed a bear yay oh now
we're going back
squeak squeaks creek
wait what's here what's this stuff
level five i don't think we can attack
non-caucus wants us to say
team coco sends the regards when we kill
something
oh i see
maesters tower i need to build a
maester's town i let's i don't want to
build one because i hate the maesters
first of all m-a-e come on man
uh that's like me i'm with the last one
what's this beth is real she's just off
camera
uh but she's not in the room right now
we can't attack people with shields it
keeps telling me to upgrade to a level
two city wall
upgrade okay go to the barracks and
upgrade it
upgrade what happened vishvendra has a
spanish test in six hours
go to sleep bishvendra we'll be here
after your spanish test come on back and
see us and tell us how you did yeah
exactly
uh claim
upgrade really this game is fun uh i
will say
the marching is a little slow yeah and i
wish that there are more things other
than boars that we could kill
i feel like it's that thing of like you
have to build the stuff yeah
gain the right to do the more you gotta
get into it you gotta spend a little
time investing yeah you're you're going
to want it you're going to want to get
into that for sure
um yes that's true i'm going to
october bill conan currently i think
conan what time is it now he's in his
rehearsals almost started i think what
time is it uh it's
1 48. we'll be coming back from lunch
and comedy rehearsal will start now
rehearsal the day i think started at 12
40 i believe uh which is very exciting
hey i'm glad you liked sophie tucker
yeah yeah sophie tucker was great and
we're going to have an exclusive
performance uh from them
later on this evening yeah they're sung
drinky which
drinky big big dance party
those guys are really cool it's a party
yeah cover cover salt says uh more bores
i
i agree i think this game needs more
boars okay
it's not boring enough thank you
up top that's the gum hand so now you've
touched the gum
i'm gonna see how many people i could
touch with my gum hand in 24 hours
guess what spoiler alert gonna be a lot
more bores
nobody wins just i'm just trying to move
us forward billy bob wait
we're we're not butchering anything
that's the problem i think i think we
need to butcher more things in this game
gump hashtag gum hand
oh digger who that's not true if you
write that again i'll be fired
i didn't actually i didn't get any fan
arts on tumblr's
touching the gum has made me patient
zero that's true it's like that movie
contagion
do you see justin hoffman movie no no
that's outbreak contagion is the one
ah soderbergh you got your matt damon's
you got you're going to paltrows
uh it's dope kate winslet's in it it's
awesome it's amazing
amazing i don't remember by the way
don't watch that movie if you're gonna
travel in the next like
year because it makes you not want to
touch anything
um i am spreading my hair you know how
you have the ability to
i need some kind of like anti
i almost said antioxidants but that's
not what i would need i know you do this
for a living but i don't know how you're
able to play a game
and talk to people oh um i post a thing
my brain is broken because while i'm
doing this
i'm not listening to whatever i know
because i'm asking you to kill things
and you're not you're only building time
you're fortifying the wall yay all right
we'll go back to attack mode i thought
i'd get it if i get to a higher level
we could attack more than boars yes how
do we know what level we're at
tinnell we will be playing a bunch of
old school games later this evening i'm
very excited about that because i love
level am i i'm not sure i think you're
gonna
attack this it'll tell you bandit camp
you're level uh level two high
okay where am i find me i think you're
far
away you know what go oh you're five
leaks you want to go down into the left
down to the left see the five leagues
think because they have two leagues
that's you right there that's us
cute how about this level three i love
it bloke
do it march too high wait what about the
thing on the left what's that sawmill
thing what's the thing on the left that
thing can you
let us gather them no no no no gathering
no we want to we want to try
no we want to destroy something oh
good gravy can't give me a
do it i might can i assume we're still a
level one house guys
oh i love it level one get in there get
it
march slots we need more march slots bro
what does that mean i don't know
what that means i wait go to go to hit
go to
or goto i don't know i don't know how to
say that
i can't build the maesters tower protect
those jerseys oxidization exactly
we're level four says you how do you
know that you
okay required keep level four
what rock static don't worry we're
almost finished
with this i'll keep upgrading
uh non cassis it's gonna be later
tonight we're gonna play some super
mario run don't worry
upgrade uh conan o'brien lucky conan's
uh gonna be checking in here in a minute
upgrade oh my god this guy i think we
broke his brain
all right tell me when i can wait martin
says he'll give me ten
thousand dollar if i cut of
the other guy's beard right now on
camera proof
if i cut off show me the money yes send
me the money oh yeah we'll take your
word on it yeah
you're in it no problem snippety snip
snap snip chat room
now wait a second let me ask you a
question can i ask you a question about
because this is kind of a spoilery
stream
what is the future of this beard yeah
are you
what is this going to be a shape is it
going to be a thing i'm going to go fork
are you going to go long
i can braid it over your you can i can't
braid it really i think the goal
for me is too long like when i know it's
too long
then i'll address the scene when is that
though exactly
we'll find out oh you don't know yeah
that's what i'm saying well we'll see
how it gets
right now it just takes a little product
to tame the beast
but i'm comfortable with it speaking of
the beast
it's a lot of brushing and beard oils
and
pomades and
yeah how much product goes in here every
every morning
minimum two minimum two what do they do
what do the two things do the oil to
give it a sheen it does have a great
sheen or i can put a leave-in
conditioner in here
okay and then i like a little bit of a
of a cream or a
wax or like mayonnaise yeah like a like
and i just work it in there to sort of
keep the shape okay it doesn't get the
shape of the old
otherwise that's how it comes that's how
it stays maintenance is the key you can
do anything you've had a beard like you
can do anything you
have i have one right now what do you
mean oh my god a beard
look at this [ __ ] this guy's throwing to
me you've had a beard
what is this i'm saying wow wow
look at you up on your beard pedestal
well if it's not a half a foot it's not
all i have
it's stubborn what else do i have to
show it's stubble
mine used to be all dark and now it's uh
click something wait for timers got it i
mean
it is a good beard bros stubble says
tootly
kill a level two creature yeah i'd love
to if i could find one
creature found great take me to it here
it is
we're attacking go to it oh we need more
march slots
oh the maesters get us again oh i can't
stand these dumbbells you know what
you're right i hate maesters
i hate it see you come around kill a
level two creature i can't do that
thanks a lot okay i guess it's just a
bunch of upgrading let's just upgrade
i'm parched if i get water will you
panic no i'm not gonna pan i don't panic
for anything i'm going to forage for
water the only thing that beer is
missing is some gum what about when roey
comes back i just shove some gum right
in his face
he just weeps hates me bandit camp guess
what we can't march
and then i'd have to cut it out level
four we can't do any more marching
because of the maesters we're trapped in
a hellish
maester dumb
thing i don't even know what this is
what i think for this reason i wasn't a
big fan of simcity oh
god for what you oh you weren't a big
fan of sim city i don't think
i think it was a lot i thought i want to
go back i want to go back quickly to
just monument valley too
because we're trapped in this mate this
hell of maester stuff
uh so i want to go back because that was
a fun we only got nine more minutes with
you so
let's play a game that we can enjoy fair
enough
um we'll leave the castle up though
because how cool does this look
no wait have you have you been inside a
real castle in your life i was in
scotland and there were castles there i
was young but i remember
not that young because i drank some
scotch
yeah somebody stole some scotch in the
mini from his parents mini bar in their
room
uh you've been to scotland right no i
want to go
love to go you're a well-traveled young
man i'm surprised uh
yeah i've been in haiti and italy in the
past yeah that's right
all right our girls coming up here you
play this game okay now this is
where name is our name is ro and we're
we're introducing our child
to the valley i don't know what that
means uh it could be north hollywood
i do i've got two kids in the valley
yeah exactly this is just my this is
just getting the kids one time because
that is that's all this game is actually
all right mm-hmm very excited so now am
i already playing i thought this was
loading no you're playing you gotta now
you tap where to go so you want to go up
to that orange square
all right yeah there you go you're gonna
want to go up over there
um we've got ruthie putting out a bunch
of cards down here i wonder what this is
going to be
this is exciting i love it there's a lot
of cards happening down here i don't
know that's a good this is an important
i love this
this is going to be great um
so this game is kind of like mcs you
remember m.c escher does the hand draw
in the hand
this is my mcs oh yeah yeah yeah pretty
good do you knew it right when i did
that that's pretty good
uh so you could twist stuff and then
perspective changes
you're trying to get to that you want to
hit that yeah you want to get to that
square
so you see you can twist this thing oh
yeah
i see oh yeah isn't that crazy mind
bending right
right and then there and then i would
can i twist we have clash royale i think
we probably do
my all-time favorite game oh that's
tough
how did you twist my most recent
favorite you can't twist it when you're
on it
got it um
this is you remember you are a jerk
what am i a jerk for do you remember how
much i hated portal
and then twist the thing it's so easy
this is worse there's like one of these
games is playing it with you yelling at
me i don't know what you're talking
about that's my normal speaking
voice um there you go look at this look
at this move look at this move i see it
i see it coming
no the other yes he did it guys he
twisted a thing
sorry i'm sorry what's really sad is how
proud of myself i am for accomplishing
that
at least we're not fighting any boars
there yeah fair enough um
all-time favorite game my most recent uh
it's i can't say my all-time favorite
game there's so many great games braid
is great
uh i loved um i got really into
uh inside was an amazing game uh
my most recent favorite game was uh
a game i love but i hated the name the
name is hellblade
sensuous sacrifice but
it's a terrible name but it's a great
game really fun
um i love so far my favorite games we
played my name of valley 2 is amazing
lumio city is awesome i've never fixed a
circuit board with lemons before
so we're definitely going to go back to
that game at some point in the stream
because
you boys got to fix that find out what's
going on that mayor with too many cats
i'm getting back in there okay i love
your friends um i'm the third person
i see your boy you're talking about
myself no wait uh
the worst um worst person ever wait i
can't move it when i'm on it
oh i hate this game so much already uh
dizzy death a time between super mario
bros 3 and sonic 2 we're gonna be
playing super mario brothers run
and sonic dash later so stay tuned uh
sonic and super mario both have amazing
games on google play
and if you're just joining us you're
watching the team coco 24 hour
mobile marathon sponsored by google play
we're going to be here until
noon tomorrow that's right we're just
getting started y'all
i'm tapping my watch which is all black
and has black hands really bad idea for
trying to check it you can't see
anything it's just a black
and i solved another children yes dude
you did
i did it yeah look at that i love it now
it sinks into the ground into your desk
just a hole fills with water and you
drown
it's a sad clap it was a sad clap and by
the way there's like 20 people in here
and only one person
left um yes we're playing monument
valley too thank you sean cynical uh
last day on earth amir we've got that
loaded up for a little bit later too
um oh this is a little creepy
ooh can we get a clock over laces
american slime i don't know
you know what we'll work on that and get
back to you because i could see the
people in the control room
uh blood coming out of their ears when i
said can we get a clock overlay
and in a bad way not like the cool fun
blood coming out of your way but in the
way that they're worried
and yes what is that yeah i was touching
conan's gum with my hand and now it's
really close to my mouth so apologies
um was sona with us in italy she wasn't
she had better things to do
which was not come with us to italy um
because you know are we taking requests
yeah let us know what games you want us
to play
i d you dare me to play a horrible
dating sim uh i play games to escape my
real life
thanks so we won't be playing any
horrible dating games thank you
um oh that'd be great would be great
just uh you know like just just the
multiple choice
dating game of like watching just how
badly you can do on a first date
how that goes wrong just like the
the menus come out and blay already
messes up the order
yeah last thing i was on i burned myself
with the candle on the table by the way
it's not a joke
exactly not a joke the waiter's not even
there um
you've already offended the host blaise
conan's babe
god that's not true no let's never say
that again
the gum will give you nightmares tonight
the gum is giving me nightmares now it's
giving me waking nightmares it's
horrifying
uh fallout shelter we've got loaded up
too octoberville we're gonna play all
these great games
uh criminal case it's all good look at
you look at you solving monument valley
too it's amazing
we found your game we found your game
dude we found your game
you're a father this is a game about a
woman and her child i think it's very
close to your heart
uh you find life very puzzling this game
is full of puzzles
i think that's amazing too this is made
for you man
if beth was here we'd do our cool uh
gear
handshake that we came up with which was
like this look at this i'm watching yeah
okay you weren't impressed like you want
you want me to do it let's try it ready
it start wait it start no it's it's like
this
and it go it go our fingers go
intertwined and then you touch
thumbs you come up slap on the back
did he come back down okay we almost had
it though we almost had it that was
great we almost had it
um all right well i think it's i think
it's two o'clock we don't need to
oh i can't sit and play this puzzle game
more can i take it with me
no can i sit and play these child's
puzzles oh my god give me that instead
of working
you're done uh two o'clock i think it's
time we check in with uh
well first of all let's thank roy
hirschkivs everybody
hey roy uh stay here roy stay here uh
and we're gonna check in with conan
let's check in right now with cob
okay it is now two o'clock
you've eaten now you're digesting blood
is going to your stomach
to digest the food that you had at lunch
so
uh your decision-making is probably not
great and some of you may be feeling
sleepy
right now but i just wanted to know that
that's typical between the hours of say
two and three i'm just gonna check in
every now and then not everything i talk
about
is gonna be related to food uh i could
talk about other things as well
the sun is of course starting its trek
uh towards the west it's uh
nightly ritual it's headed there too
so it's not at its highest point right
now a lot of people don't notice
the sun in this digital age they don't
think about it
you guys are kids watching are probably
like what are we farmers what do we care
you shouldn't know where the sun is sun
at two o'clock it's
starting to make its way down towards
the western part of the horizon
but still early on its journey
boy i bet you wish i wasn't checking in
huh this is some pretty shitty stuff i'm
saying
i'll see it a little bit
hey everybody uh thank you for uh
joining us
uh you're watching the 24 hour mobile
marathon brought to us by brought uh
in conjunction with google play we're
playing mobile games for 24 hours we're
just saying goodbye
to roy herschkovitz give him a hand
everybody give him a hand
thanks roy thanks thanks thanks uh give
me some tingles anyway i'll give you
some tickets
welcome our next guests we're gonna show
a little remote
uh this is a man who keeps it all
running because he keeps the big man
happy it's uh mr david hopping and we
did an amazing remote with him
we're gonna watch right now so take a
look hey conan o'brien here
well here's the good news i'm in my 25th
year
as a late night host started out in 1993
25 years still going strong everything's
terrific
but there's one problem nobody talks
about what if something were to happen
to me
i know don't get upset i live kind of a
fast dangerous life
and i have a lot of enemies so i can go
at any time
that's why i've been thinking about a
replacement
someone young virile who can step in and
is ready to be
the next conan o'brien ladies and
gentlemen meet
david hopping david step on in here hey
david hey
and you've been working for me for how
long you're gonna have now year and a
half yeah okay where are you from david
uh southern illinois small town named
carlinville okay didn't really ask about
the town
i need there to be someone waiting in
the wings to step in as conan o'brien
should that be necessary okay and i
thought you're a young guy
you seem very likable would you like to
be the next conan o'brien why not
i mean why not aren't you like what
about oh my god i don't think i could do
that
that's insane he's up here and i'm down
here
why did you just act like this is no big
deal let's
uh thank you okay the point is this
you don't seem at all in awe who me
i can't pull the sword out of the stone
and be king arthur it seems easy to you
doesn't it to fill in for conan o'brien
i don't know
what do you mean you don't know do you
think you can just step into my shoes
probably not you can't just be me
i can't you need training okay i'm sorry
i yelled at you okay
are you a fan of my comedy i am
it's just i'm sorry not just not like
wow yes
you meant a lot to me as a kid you did
if you're going to be conan o'brien i
need to know that you are fit
healthy and you're going to live a long
long time let's go through it
cardiovascular system any heart problems
nope any problems with your liver
pancreas gallbladder or hernia no
are you pregnant no have you used lsd
heroin cocaine or any other narcotic
depressant stimulant or psychedelic
whether or not prescribed by a physician
within the last five years no
you haven't used any of those cocaine
no lsd no uppers no downers
bennies blue jackets red yellows
you have a pleasant odor
okay follow my finger
do you see my finger no that's not good
let's get you looking like me shall we
let's do it
okay i'm told that david is ready with
his makeover david
[Music]
you look like conan o'brien like you
yeah how do you feel
feel good yeah yeah are you excited to
look this way the rest of your life
yeah i'm being totally honest i'm
attracted to right now
okay i'm just saying that
not in a sexual way okay um
i guess what other way is there now i
think the first thing we're going to do
is learn how to act like conan o'brien
around the office
okay you ready for that ready so i know
what do you think
i think it's it's very creepy he looks
like you that's fantastic i'm now going
to teach david how to interact
with you sona okay we have a very
specific kind of chemistry
okay dysfunctional it's a little
dysfunctional okay okay
what usually happens is i walk in and
sona what are you usually watching on
your computer screen honestly
uh right now i'm binge watching cheers
you're watching an mdc
show from 35 years ago let's say i
needed a prescription
yes what would come first you getting me
the prescription are you finishing the
cheers episode and be honest
i would finish the cheers episode does
that sound reasonable to you
no david now you're coming this is you
need that prescription
sona i need that prescription you're
watching cheers
everyone you're seeing on your screen
right now is dead
try it try it sona i need that
prescription
no that's not how you do it say who's
printing who's printing say i demand a
note
i demand to know who's printing that was
me what
grab these papers and hold them in her
face and say you printed something while
i was talking
yeah go you printed these while i was
talking that's outlandish
unheard of it says balderdash i'm sorry
i could jump up and down
jump up and down that's not mad jumping
up and down
yeah i'm training because as you know
i'm not getting any younger right
you said it no that's your cue to say
what are you talking about
you look like what are you late twenties
what are you talking about what are you
late
twenties i don't know everybody
but i do a lot to look like a friendly
guy without knowing their name as i call
everybody chopper
okay hey there chopper hey there
we're gonna go in and talk to the
writers now they're meeting okay
the way i usually do it is i kick open
the door okay
i make a lot of kind of silly
over-the-top jokes about
how horrible the writing's been lately
even when it's been good okay
[Applause]
last time i saw [ __ ] piled up this high
i was in a barnyard
i always leave the room on a huge laugh
so take care of that
[Music]
so long you pieces of [ __ ]
which is to talk to jordan schlansky so
you're trying to make him then you look
like you no he is the new conan okay
he's going to be trained to be the
newcomer is the intent that he would
fool someone and they wouldn't notice
the switch
he's just going to be cone let's just
see if we can recreate some of our
classic chemistry
what do you do here at the conan show i
have various administrative tasks
what does that even mean there are
certain logistical matters that need to
be
tended to that his desk is a mess
and sweep everything here onto the floor
oh just no one says fragile though
it's probably not don which is an
italian brand of
porcelain and uh lavazza espresso cups
used to be
see that was reckless wants and violence
that leads to nothing
if i had acid right now i poured in your
eyes
big part of my job is walking around the
warner brothers lot you know being conan
o'brien it's a thrill for people to see
me
okay say hey folks hey folks say conan
o'brien
brian here hi hello what's up asked this
woman what's your name hi what's your
name
well you're a big fan of his now he's a
big fan of his he's the new conan
o'brien
she's from south korea i went to south
korea yes i've seen that episode
[Applause]
chase the tram now and say i'm really
needy i'm really needy
i'm really needy i'm really needy
i'm so needy i need more laughter
[Laughter]
this laughter makes up for my home life
well david we spent a couple of hours
with each other i've tried to teach you
everything i can there's just one last
test you ready i'm ready
all right you have to
kill me guess what
you just passed you just passed the test
it's a
weird test yeah someone david hopping
the new conan
what's up and david hopkins
that's a big part of the job
congratulations thank you this is going
to be big for you we'll be right back
say who's coming on we'll be right back
with dj khaled
[Applause]
okay hi
[Music]
i'm david um and uh
we should say what we do on the show i'm
conan o'brien's
executive assistant and i'm a personal
production assistant to
conan and jeff our executive producer
it's a long title
it's a very long title and we are for
the next hour
going to be part of the mobile marathon
the 24-hour mobile
marathon brought to you by google play
yes
and we're playing animal crossing i've
never played
i've never played that either right do
you play video games
sometimes i'm not a big gamer but
let's i guess cross some animals yeah
i'm playing a game now i forgot what
it's called but it's
this little like yarn person do you know
this game
this yarn person comes huh
it's a little yarn guy who comes out of
an old lady's house
and he's like using his like yarn to
swing on things
and then he unravels and you have to go
buy a bunch of yarn and then you
re-ravel little big plan huh i have i
have actually no idea what it's called
oh okay all right yeah so now we're
playing
uh animal crossing and by we i mean just
david
you're ready
all right that's fine
someone is asking how abusive is conan
honestly
very abusive both physically
and verbally abusive
that's it
[Music]
just downloading and how did you guys
get your jobs
uh so i was at intern like may 2014
then after that i was a tour guide on
the warner brothers lot
about a year and a half gave those tours
and then i started working here about a
little over a year and a half ago
yeah and david's awesome i um uh
applied to be a pa on the show and then
just interviewed to be conan's assistant
it's uh yeah i did not intern
i didn't know anybody on the show i just
uh just did it
just did it all right welcome to it
would it be cool if i ask you a question
right let's say your invitation started
the world okay would we explore nature
go far far away or just chill out i i
just chill out but i feel like that's
a boring answer okay what you do
you need both my friends
sometimes i wonder if i should have been
a fisherman
well i think you're headed in the right
direction enjoy the peace and quiet
and game over
[Music]
this is nice
so what is conan's favorite food
[Laughter]
uh pizza i think it's pizza
he's a very thing about pizza
hey sonnet does your family still bother
you about getting married
no because i am getting married oh
so they're not bothering me anymore all
right
okay let's let's make you
all right i'm gonna let you make me okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna make you
you're very pale that's you it's
okay cheeks
i gave you little rosy cheeks that's
david
okay all right
i don't know what this is
has anyone ever played this game
very relaxing no one's ever played
there's a van and a little person
there's david
okay you drag your finger across the
string you're okay
tap anyone or anything that catches your
eye all right questions you know he's
okay
all right
oh welcome can you do all this in a
different voice
me yeah ah welcome you must be the new
camp manager i've been waiting for it's
great to meet you
i think that's really that person's
personnel
no need to be modest i've heard great
things about you
now i have you all registered and
everything but i'm not quite sure how to
pronounce your name
you're good
that's me
do it all right welcome to your new
campsite smart
my name is she looks like an isabelle
she looks like an isabelle
and it's my pleasure to show you around
and explain how things work all right
isabelle
as a camp manager you've got the run of
this place
you can set up amenities and furniture
any way you like there are so many
possibilities we get to
set up furniture
[Music]
what
i'll do my best i'll do my best
god this is so much dialogue yeah dude
the animals ever cross is my question
how would you describe your ideal
campsite in one word
natural cute sporty cool
uh
oh my gosh
all right
all right let's go
[Music]
fulfill animal request
there i am
i guess we'll talk to that
i'm gonna let you read this now hey i
don't know you do i
really i'm asking you who's noggin what
it used to be
oh it's your name great to meet you
kiddo
hey we got a life i miss this why are
you talking to a bird
what is it that brings you this little
slice of paradise
i'll tell you right off the bat that i'm
here for the fruit
all right i guess i can bring you the
bring
you do that for me well you're all right
in that case could i trouble you for an
apple
hey we got a life this this requires
zero
skill this game you can shake any tree
just by tapping on it shaking will knock
the fruit to the ground
got it let's go
we'll go shake the tree oh
sure oh
let's go
oh wait i came back to the original
campsite on accident
james francis is asking why are you guys
playing a child game
i don't know i really don't have an
answer
all right i am failing so hard
okay we've already talked to that
oh here shake it
sona do you have to laugh at all of
conan's jokes
no and i don't
i'm just reading all the like comments
not all of them
somebody on twitch says my mom says that
game it's too scary
you're right it's terrifying someone
youtube asked if you're really an
assistant or just a make
believe actress oh
i'm really an assistant i show you my
paycheck
now we got a reward
[Music]
the chiefs dude zero says are you guys
gamers no
absolutely not
somebody says your hair looks like
michael keaton
i don't know if that means your hair
looks like michael katen or if
your hair looks like michael keaton's
hair
okay and now yes we just gotta
no
oh there's more no
we got cherries
someone wants to know what your hobbies
are um
[Music]
i guess i know eating is a really big
hobby of mine
it's a good one
um
got it let's keep fruit
there's not much happening
oh there's more what is that pear
and then we can come back in three hours
and get more pairs from the same tree
can you pick up that bucket and that
water
go back towards that tree this one
you gotta go around it oh
no that's stupid
no they meant michael keaton's hair okay
good thank you for clarifying
thank you all right i'm gonna slowly
walk back
and give him his fruit
do you still have the jiggles mug yes i
do still have it
i have i actually have four now because
showtime sent me
a lot of them and i don't know what
happened to i think i had 12 at one
point
and then uh i think people just stole
them
and now i only have four maybe three
somebody asked who's taking care of
conan right now
literally no one nobody said nobody not
a single person because the two people
who would be taking care of him are
playing this animal game there's the
phone rings
we're looking for fake fruit which i'm
doing
this show he's probably hungry and
scared and lonely
that's got to be all the fruity ones
i think i came here take this
the way he's talking is terrible look
how happy i am with my basket of fruit
i'm enjoying fresh fruit with apollo
we did it you did it
we got we got 300 bells stop saying we
really that was all you you were here
for support though
i want you i told you to go to a bucket
you couldn't do anything
with
all right this one's all you french
friendship level
up i had no idea this was about
friendship i love friendship
okay oh
all this dialogue is what's really i
hope our path across again shmarp i'll
definitely keep my eye out for you take
care kiddo
i wonder if my campsite's ready
all right
sit on this lock wait why did he sit on
the log
who did this who made this game who made
this game
who did this game nice to meet you
should we get some dominance
or wait what am i doing craft it
did i just i okay not made
complete this item right how do you get
leaf tickets
i think we have just hit yeah
somebody just asked me what the best
part of my job is i'm gonna say right
now
i'm being paid to play video games and
drink wine
yes
i can't i can't i can't do the animals
ever
cross
somebody wants to know what your major
was
communication i know it's not very
useful
but uh i mean it was it was fun you know
what i went to
the university of southern california
and they have an awesome communication
department
and i and i loved it
i loved it i loved it it's good
i miss school sometimes i really miss
school sometimes i just want to
go back and i don't know oh it's white
wine
for you just ask me
my name's david for placing items on
your campsite or inside your camper once
an item step blah blah to put things
away
you're done okay
place item
place
done safe hi sir
robster roll and poison heart 77.
um my major is also communications
that's it where it's at got us i don't
know
that's what we did place
place item done save
oh what do i do i am a production
assistant on the show to conan and jeff
the executive producer
basically i just do whatever sona tells
me that's about it
[Music]
i don't know if i could keep playing
this game oh the animals do not cross
why is it called animal crossing
wait yeah i don't know how much longer i
could play this game
you can switch should we switch
we this is we're not doing much i mean
it's it's fun
did we win
right now oh it's animal kingdom eagles
sitting on a sofa
so i and now he's sleeping
all right
how'd i do that
oh look
[Music]
oh i learned how to speed up past those
things those conversations
you're off to a great start we're only
starting
i'll do my best
like their mom on a touch screen
i'm doing an impression of my mom too
how do you turn it on son how do you
turn it on
that's my mom
okay you can now make one or more new
items
fire up your camper
how many hours a week do you work sauna
like at work or actually working there
there's a difference between
how and how many hours i'm actually
doing something that would be considered
work
[Music]
i don't know i mean normal work week and
then how many hours do i actually work
you know i don't know does do we
i mean does doing crossword puzzles
count as working
if so instead okay you're good at the
full-time job i know
i'm really good at sudoku
sona do you play video games yourself
i play video games sometimes i um
yeah i play a few video games i'm not
good at them
i just remember i think back when
super mario 2 came out i spent the
entire summer just
in the room trying to pass level three
can we yeah all right how do we do that
we're gonna switch games
do you have a hiding spot for naps one
time i walked in
so conan has this board in his office
that i update every once in a while
i go in to update it and sona's asleep
on his couch
so i just had to i just quietly closed
the door and left
oh my god oh wait
how do we do that maybe yeah or the
circle
okay okay
so what do we what are we doing now
do we just hidden folks is that in
the play store or is it do we go to the
play store
can someone help me oh wait
um yeah oh oh i should have just done it
you see it in there
all right which one you want to play i
think sausage run
what is sausage
we have to i told you that they said we
have to
you have to play this
find two more targets
what what oh so it's
this one that's like where's waldo oh
that's right do you see a snake
david who sees a snake
where's the little snake
wait is that hanging from the tree no
no we're a snake
i'll just wait until someone in the
comments tells us yeah can someone tell
us where the snake is
it's coming out of the log where's the
it's oh
well no that's the snake down here oh
we're looking for i didn't realize
look in the bushes
look at the bushes david do you see this
little snake we're trying to find so
it's the
curly one it's this curl it's this curl
the big snake is a real
real brush he's a real bushcrawler
you're really really crawling behind the
behind the middle bush
oh is that it
there we go oh we could cut things
oh i found it
the only ripe white banana is pretty
much
up for grabs where are you banana
[Music]
i have a banana joke okay
hey what's uh beethoven's favorite fruit
it's a good one i also said i have a
banana joke and then i
gave away the punchline before i said
the joke
oh wow
for this man in distress the
uncomfortable scene is police
okay for this man in distress the
uncomfortable seat is the least of his
troubles
oh no
this is this is too much this is too
much
for
[Music]
he's sitting he's sitting
[Laughter]
can i just touch things and hope i would
just like yeah
you're finding you found a bird
enthusiast
is this cheating
wait somebody hold on he's in the middle
of the river on a boat is there a river
oh is that him zoom in
what how big is this jungle oh
look how big this jungle is oh this is
the river
on a boat
is there another oh what's that
man in distress who did that it's gone
who did that oh wait dead word dog
good job edward dog he's in the middle
of the river he's doing all caps too
he's like
pay attention if you ask
classy jessie treetop naps are the best
this is how i like i normally just play
games
when that's how old we are i'm 26. i
don't know if you wanna
you're not supposed to ask ladies their
age i'm 35.
it got so quiet
[Music]
what's the name of this game again this
is
hidden folks hidden folks
this guy's on top of a tree
who knows who knows where classy jesse
is
treetop naps are the best
sona can you be my mom
i mean i guess
someone put a lot of time classy jesse
the woman with a guitar plays music that
will warm the hearts of men in reptiles
all right on the tree house is that what
one year's found
play it again
[Music]
are you hitting something or is it just
doing that
i'm hitting it i'm hitting it oh
[Music]
david stop it i don't even have that
stop it david
don't even have the tablet um
[Music]
she's playing with a guitar plays music
that will warm the hearts of
men and reptiles uh of course
so we're looking for a lady with a
guitar
do you see it oh my god we didn't even
need help on that one
oh no wishes he had paid more attention
during his tai chi class
what's his what's his sound
[Laughter]
i can't stop
we gotta look for people doing tai chi
hey i'm crushing
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh you're wasting everyone's time i'm so
sorry
we're looking for
i am downloading this game
did you hear did you hear someone speak
oh fluffy panda
when i say the name fluffy panda that is
not the voice you should drink more of
your wine
i'm almost done
[Music]
i don't know what i'm doing check the
bridge on the right
check the bridge on the right on the
right
no is there another bridge
is there another bridge yeah say it
louder that's how
it works internet is there another
bridge
do you see a black monkey making this
noise
do you see a white do you see a white
monkey making this noise
okay that's the exact same noise hold on
one's making
help me internet the others watching
jealousy sits on a throne of bananas
upper left bouncing someone says
oh max area unlocked
thank you brandon chen thank you very
much
fluffy panda internet fluffy panda
top right top right
maybe not
oh nice job
the others watch jealously while king
kiki sits on his throne of bananas
the others watch jealous we need a
collection of
monkeys
[Music]
we already did that one
long elegant birds lay long elegant eggs
this chicken was a single bite-sized
dinner
chicken chicken internet
where's the chicken
this chicken was a single bite-sized
dinner
[Music]
we have three more things left to such a
small
chicken know
did anybody say it
looks more like a chicken yeah
sona can you make a monkey sound
we can do that for the rest it's on the
other side of the
road totally fell for that where's the
chickens on the other side of the road
real fun in the oven
all right you know what
we have serious business here we're
looking for a little chicken
so if no one's taking that seriously
then uh i suggest you not chime in
thanks
uh shaman
this reptile laughs so there's someone
trying to catch a butterfly oh wait
oh did you see that hold on that guy's
trying to catch a butterfly
and the reptile where's the reptile
laughing
oh my goodness
okay
let's take a walk
near the party mat in the right on the
right hand side okay
party matt
yeah oh that guy's trying to find the
uh trying to get the bird so there's a
reptile i mean not a bird
freaking butterfly that
see look the hint for that one is the
reptile laughs
so the reptile is nearby see if maybe
he's behind this bush is he behind this
bush
oh i got it i did that all on purpose
all right so we just got
[Music]
bottom right okay
i'm just gonna start
it's not working
all right where are they at wait so
you're looking for
looking for yo
bite-sized dinner chicken okay
obviously so it's around people who are
having dinner
who's eating
who's eating
they're eating someone says
near the log
is roasting over the village trash can
fire bottom left
all right one's by a log here go to the
bottom left
and then where's that are they i don't
know if they're lying
i don't know if you're lying i know
where the little hump thing right above
the log towards the right
okay what's the right look for a log
towards the right everyone's saying
there's
there's so many logs there's so many
logs though
there is a stub thank you there's a
there are logs and there are stuff
we need someone to tell us a more
accurate description of where this
chicken is
or if you see the shaman tell us where
the shaman is
okay is there there's a is there stuff
behind this can you cut these trees
no no i need to cut the bushes
the little chick is in the hump right
above the log near the bottom left okay
is in the hump right
hold on no stop stop commenting we need
to
go by the snakes
it's on the it's on the left
okay by a a hump is this the hum
yeah no
i'm just waiting look for the smoke from
the fire
someone is saying that in all caps so
look for if it's in all caps it's gotta
be
okay bottom right
no not what that's not snake
all right i get that
i'm just gonna start
people are saying left people are saying
right
oh there's a fire
left camilla where
left go left camilla where
the shaman behind the waterfall okay
where's the waterfall
is there a waterfall right side middle
bottom-ish
come on kaiser whoever you are kaiser i
can't with you
the shaman is behind the waterfall find
the water okay we're zooming all the way
out now
again waterfall waterfall
tune down for what i get it i did i set
him up
did i set you up for that joke did i set
you up for that joke not your left milo
the chicken on the bed in the bed tree
bot
left bottom right okay everyone's saying
i'm gonna be really mad if we never do
you guys think this is a joke
this is very serious with two things
left we have to get just tell us where
they are
my method of just clicking all over the
screen is not
working chicken there in the snake right
hand side below the river
where is the river okay is that that's
just a little
that's the pond okay here's the river
there's eggs i'm not looking for eggs
david
no good chicken
i don't think there's a chicken i'm with
you
uh i don't believe what
i don't think it's going to do that
who said that who said that who said
that
who said that bottom right behind the
waterfall
okay
you know what i think that was kaiser
and earlier kaiser i may have said that
you
were lying to us and i apologize
and i'm sorry thank you so much you're
right the snake ate the chicken
is that him we
it says you found them all state why
would anybody stay
longer nothing to do take a walk
thank you everybody for your help with
that that was very exciting
me yuri were you the one who told me
about this who told me about the snake
who said the snake ate the chicken
[Music]
how did you get it to start before help
help that walking folk get across
what do we do
of them have to get across everybody
i'm definitely gonna go download this
and play this at my desk me too the rest
of the day
what is it called hidden what hit him
hidden folks everyone it has mine and
david hoppings
we're very excited about it although i
don't know how i'm going to play this
without
i need people to tell me where yeah
people saying where it is
where everything is hidden folks is the
game thank you yes
thank you all right
fix the pathway someone said okay all
capital the all caps is helpful
how do i fix it though
[Music]
this is working
oh
these type of games are good for
airplanes it's true that's very true i'm
sorry i just grabbed this no i was doing
terrible
how do we change
[Music]
like where's waldo except where's
chicken
how do you fix the pathway
i don't know
someone says double tap oh i didn't know
you could double pass
[Music]
someone says notice me i crave attention
we notice you
we notice you we value you
you are important
who's more clueless
i told we fixed the path we're doing our
best
we're trying bro but
i think that's all we got i think we're
done
are we done we're out of time we're done
all right all right it's three o'clock
time to check in with conan bye
oh that's great i just play a song uh
that we can't afford to play on the
internet
but it was beautiful it was amazing and
i just finished with that chord if you
can figure out which chord it is you win
nothing it's three o'clock now
but some of you are starting to feel a
little peckish you want a little
something like a snack
i'm fine with a snack i would suggest
nuts
nuts are good um but remember use your
hand as a guide uh
if you're having a handful of nuts
that's fine you know
but if you're having two or three
handfuls of nuts well that's just gonna
be stored fat later on
man you can't get advice like this other
places
that's the cool thing about hanging with
me i'm a pretty
smooth character well it is three as i
said i hope you're having a good time
we are now three hours into this
experiment
and some people say nothing like this
has ever been tr what's that
oh people do this all the time i'm sorry
but this was like some groundbreaking
thing
but anyway three o'clock
sun heading further to the west food
digested you might need a snack
i'll see in a little bit hey everybody
what's going on welcome back to the 24
hour mobile marathon sponsored by google
play let's hear it again for sonum
obsession and david hopping
it's great conan unattended probably
wandering around the warner brothers
lot drooling trying to find where the
coffee is he doesn't know what he's
doing because those are the people who
take care of him and actually make our
show
run so thank you sona and david i hope
you guys
had a good time i'm very loud that's
true yes
now you have a person with a big head
speaking a lot of voice i got i was in
choir
i got a lot i got a good diaphragm going
on is that what's called diaphragm
oh boy we got steve hollander over here
this is exciting um
so we're gonna uh cycle the stream
everybody so if you see a little bit of
interruption
in your uh in your viewing that's what
it's gonna be
uh we gotta keep this thing going for 24
hours live and
to do that we have to talk to the robots
and ask the robots uh
to continue doing these streams because
the robots don't want us to
uh so we got a lot of great games coming
up a lot of great guests coming up
a lot of great exclusive music
performances coming up maybe a little
behind the scenes goo maybe some
costumes maybe some snacks
who knows uh i changed my shirt to this
thing that says puppies love me
uh and it's not ironic because puppies
do love me so this is just
some people wear ironic shirts this is
not one of those this is a
true truth shirt holland do you want to
come on camera
i'm good oh okay stage adventure steve
hollander otherwise known as my show dad
i gotta laugh on him uh he told me to
keep my wallet in my front pocket so it
doesn't hurt my back and i don't and it
has hurt my back uh very much
oh look at this he's saying oh handed me
a open water by the way
there we go perfect um so coming up a
little bit later
uh we are going to have um
some very special people stopping by
we're super excited
if you've seen our show you know who
they are now
uh here's the thing oh
son and dave are coming back in why what
did you guys forget
ah perfect uh they actually don't work
here
um so now what do that well we're gonna
play a game
um that's pretty intense
uh because we've done hidden folks which
is basically where's waldo
we did some animal crossing this is on
the next level this is on the next level
we're gonna uh
you guys are gonna see the true power of
mobile gaming i'm very excited about it
oh boy
i don't want to load any game data uh
okay
um but before we do that uh
we're gonna take a look at uh a clip of
a person
who we are uh very excited to welcome
but i can't do it yet can i
no we have to recycle this change